this is Jocko podcast number 191 with
echo Charles and me Jacques are willing
good evening echo good evening some
nights I wake up drenched in sweat I
have dreams and some people might call
them nightmares but that would not be
accurate because I'm not scared and I'm
not anxious I'm actually amped and I'm
ready and the dream is usually about
some bad situation unfolding really
quickly some operation gone the sideways
and I'm in a building somewhere or in a
bunker or under a ravine of some kind
and the enemy is maneuvering then
they're bringing it and I'm with a small
group a squad maybe six or eight guys
and we're low on ammo then I'm about out
and one of the guys is hit and he's hit
bad and we can't move and we can't leave
and this is it
and the enemy is pressing closer and I'm
prepping grenades and as I'm prepping
grenades I got my head down because
they're laying down fire and the enemy
is advancing and we're killing some of
them but others are getting through and
the enemy fire increases and if I'm in a
building I I hear the door open up and I
can hear them entering the building and
I do a quick assessment I got three
grenades and I got a half a mag
then I got my K bar then I'm ready to
get it on and I pull the pin on one of
the grenades and I roll it down the
hallway toward the stairs and it
explodes then I hear RPGs launch and one
explodes a little distance away but then
the next one explodes on the wall right
near me and it knocks me out and then
and then I come to and I check for my
rifle and grabbing for my rifle but it's
not there and so I reached for my pistol
but my pistols gone too and then I feel
for the rest of my dear I feel for my
knife I feel for grenades and there's
nothing there all my gear is gone I feel
for wounds and there's nothing and then
I realized that I'm okay that I'm just
sweating a lot that there's no gear
there's no guns and I realized that I
was asleep and that this was just a
dream and now I'm laying there in a pool
of sweat in my bed then I'm awake and
I'm I'm actually mad because I left my
boys hanging there in my dream and I'm
also mad because I don't get that final
confrontation with the enemy and I'll
sit there and close my eyes and I'll try
and fall back asleep I'll try to force
myself back in there so I can finish the
fight but I can't force myself to fall
back asleep so I lie there in bed and I
start thinking about what I would have
done I start thinking if there's any
mistakes that I made I start thinking
about if how I could have defended that
position where I would have maneuvered
to how I could have maximized damaged to
the enemy and then I think about
the rest of the guys on the team and I
think if I was in that situation
who would I want with me and this was
this was a common topic in the teams if
you were in a desperate scenario with
the odds stacked against you if it was
time for the last stand for victory or
death who would you want with you I have
a list of those names those men a list
of the guys I want with me in that most
critical of moments and when I think
about that list there's always one guy
that comes to mind first the guy that
I've seen perform on the battlefield not
for an hour not for a day or not for a
week but for months on end this guy
would go out on a three day operation in
120 degree heat with two liters of water
three cans of Copenhagen and twice as
many bullets as anyone else and as soon
as the mission was over he'd want to go
back out again this is a guy that can
lead and that can follow a guy that can
plan and execute a guy that never put
himself above the good of the mission or
above the good of his teammates and I
know without a shred of doubt that he
would have rather himself be killed or
wounded than watch me be killed or
wounded he would step into the line of
fire take a bullet or jump on a grenade
to protect me or any of our brothers in
arms' that's the guy I'm talking about
and the other thing is I know what he's
thinking and he knows what I'm thinking
there's no need to even talk we were
raised at the same team by the same
people we don't have to debate or
discuss whether we should do this or do
that we look at each other give a little
nod and we know what we need to do so if
I have to assault a beach or attack a
bunker or storm the gates of hell
I want my brother Tony efrati by my side
btf Tony big tough frogman and that's
what he is through and through and
that's what he did for his entire career
through eight overseas deployments he
was one of the first guests I had on the
podcasts podcast number 41 if you
haven't listened to that podcast stop
and go back and listen to it but if you
had live have listened to it well then
here we go again with btf Tony Tony
welcome back
yeah let's just deployments are ten ten
ten deployments no but let's just get
back because I didn't want you to get
wounded cuz you so there's such a
monster that's a carry you be a little
better if like I go wanted I could put
you in my cargo pod right yeah we're
good yeah BT EPS great big tougher I'm
not big I'm not really tired wackadoo
you know so last time you were on we
kind of just jumped right into like
going into the teams and everything and
which men we skeptic skipped over a
bunch of stuff like I mean not a bunch
but I mean because like I know you're
gonna put it well how'd you grow up why
cool up and then I
so so you grew up you grew up in New
England yeah New Hampshire and and did
you play sports yeah I played hockey and
baseball did they issue you a hockey
stick when you were born in New
Hampshire yeah it's pretty much you get
one in kindergarten and then then you
play street hockey and you learn how to
you know like rough up your buddies and
then get your ass kicked and then you
just keep playing did you play organized
hockey oh yeah yeah I play rock hockey I
played youth hockey all the way up till
I was like 17 no kidding yep
they lie all my life three years old
till like 17 you kept all your teeth
yeah pretty much
I played a might squirts bantams and
midgets there's four categories wise
yeah I played a lot of hockey and till I
got a little bit older and then you know
had to work yeah so schoolwork the one a
lot of time for it and and I realized I
wasn't gonna be like wicked good so I
just it was fun well yeah yeah yeah a
chapter my life and that's it but I
still love hockey you'll love it
you know big fan and like when I was a
kid we would play like out on lakes cuz
I didn't play organized hockey did that
too yeah we would tape magazines to our
shins crowd we didn't have like the
actual new year so we just do that
that way when you get whacked with a
puck or a stick you're not just doing
now even the summers like people my age
your age everybody knows what I'm
talking about
like Saturday morning when you're little
your mother would give you breakfast to
get the hell out come back at lunch it's
not like I went in my room and went in
my little computer Lee and have any of
that
so we went like we threw rocks at each
other or play baseball in a field or
yeah you see your mom would say come
home for lunch my mom would just like
say get out
then the funny thing is what when when
it was like oh it's time to eat
it'd be like oh cool I'm gonna get a
Snickers bar and a can of coke yeah what
we ate yeah that's that's what I that's
what we ate it wasn't like when you need
to watch your content yeah what the fuck
is this glue like some stuff that floats
around in the sky like I don't know what
that is no apparently people are
allergic to it I don't know you know I
always knew about the peanuts and the
shellfish and all that shit but not
really you know you know it's on the
table eater that's it don't give a shit
yeah I just uh the things ain't even
I'll catch myself you know with my kids
going you know you don't want to drink
that soda and I'm thinking about when I
was a kid just that's that's all we
drank we didn't drink that first of all
there's no such thing as bottled water
no no it that still that Connie drinks
out of the tap yeah it's it's better
than Avion or whatever the fuck it is no
it's like the best it's like so good I
felt like fill up right in the sink and
it's still the bass yeah so you played
hockey and in what what when you went to
high school did you guys have a hockey
team in high school
now the next the next town did but we
didn't have a high school team Dead
youth hockey so then you read you know
did you play anything and did you play
any sports in high school just baseball
just baseball yeah and then I I sucked
at it but I played Little League played
into my like junior high and I bet I
sucked at baseball more than you which
was a bummer gallon quart my dad was
like a fanatic about baseball and I was
out there going this is the most boring
thing I've ever done in my whole life
ever like yeah this is I could you know
consider whatever seven years old but I
like I still be in there I like it
because now I watch baseball and I know
I get the appeal now but what I'm saying
is when I was seven year old African
hyperactive youth and my dad's like you
know this is a great game and you got to
understand the tactics in them and and
the strategy behind what's going on and
you don't care about anywhere
because the funnest thing like the
funnest sport that I remember playing
that I've said oh this is cool was
dodgeball
that was his real Island yeah you're
like oh Hawk the balls at the other
people
that was funny it's like highly active
yeah so we played rec your rec league
hockey though when I was a kid too and
that was all on outdoor rinks that's
also wooden boards and be like ten boys
here and they flood it and then like my
uncle was the coach of one of the weeks
and he was terrible like he didn't even
not escaped but and he had no idea of
how to play hockey you just kill him
weed up checking practice for an hour I
just go out there and check each other
like really you know I you know I didn't
like I mean I know how to play I know
the rules I know and this is what we're
doing Mike all right and just go out
there and kill each other yeah yeah you
and I were talking about the fact that
the hockey players are getting smaller
again now yeah there was a there was I
guess because this is distance I
wouldn't talk to the gulls the San Diego
gulls and their coach was explaining to
me cuz I said man the guys are smaller
than I expected some of them yeah and he
said I said I thought everyone was huge
now and he said no cuz now what they
figured out is these smaller faster
quicker guys have a have an advantage
that they can exploit the
maneuverability just like on the
battlefield you can exploit being able
to maneuver and these smaller quicker
guys can actually maneuver faster than
the bigger lumbering guys now the
there's position for the bigger guys to
get out of necks yeah that's what their
figure it out yeah that's a different
you know so if you were to go back in
time you might be able to you might be
able to hack it now yeah I I played
sports but my real thing was like
hunting and fishing or trapping you know
I did all that shit so that that kind of
took a higher step like that's that was
the press that's what I liked priority
for yeah I like being out in the woods
hunting was your dad in the military yes
my dad was in the army and 60s drop did
mm-hmm he wasn't in Vietnam
went to Germany rooms a helicopter
mechanic kind of last in the army you
know he's over in Germany like the
coolest guy ever
yeah yeah coolest and richest guy ever
right yes like drink beer and you know
go to work everyday and and and did he
talk to you about the military at all
Wow what made you want to join the neat
because did you join right out of high
school yeah I enlisted when I was see
six days after I turned seventeen dang
so I was in delayed entry for you huh
and then I wept six days after I turn
eight what made you want to join the
Navy because this is the thing this is
the thing that I try to warn people
about the Navy if you want to go in the
Navy and be in the SEAL Teams that's
cool and everything if you don't make it
in the SEAL Teams your job is not gonna
be that cool oh I mean unless you're
into that kind of thing because there's
some people that want to work with
technology that's cool you'll be an IT
men and then in the Navy or you want to
work with engines and your beam
engineman or you want to be a gun it's
like that's cool
if that's what you want to do but those
are industrial type jobs yeah they're 95
they're in what they're industrial jobs
they're trades right in the army like if
you don't make it to Special Forces or
you don't make it to Rangers or in the
Marine Corps if you'll make the MARSOC
you can still be an infantryman which
means you're still get to get napped or
do the machine-gun thing which is pretty
much what I think most people when they
join the military
I shouldn't say most people if you're
even thinking about Special Operations
then you want to you want to be using a
machine gun well yeah I mean you want to
have a machine gun and everyday life I
mean we're come in so handy the luminate
a lot of it's bringing a horse shit like
hey you know wait in the trap and just
get out excuse me down okay go it would
be so much easier the real I mean it's
legal but you know so you but you what
did you join the Navy to be or do you
just be like I want to be I want to be a
frogman but it took me a while it took
me a couple years to go to Budds how did
you know about this what year was this
like 86 yeah I knew about the SEAL Teams
I wanted to do it but
that the thing that helped me the most
was actually doing like two years in the
fleet mm-hmm
and yeah it's two years that could have
been a team guy but for me I wasn't
ready
it wasn't mature enough so I hadn't I
needed that structure and I learned how
the Navy works and for all you people
out there and all that I was stationed
in the Philippines for two years it's
not like I was on a boat I was just
drinking and you know just being a
madman and of course the SEAL Teams were
over there you know the West Coast guys
might yeah I mean I might as well just
do that that's like the best so I think
you listen they're 17 years old and you
get you get 18 stationed in Subic and
Subic as a what Mindlin all homes are
linemen car looks like shore duty you
know but it's like overseas duty there's
the bad insane there's the battle did
they give you did they give you any kind
of like briefing as this 18 year old kid
like okay you're in the Philippines now
this is what's about yeah they just tell
you cuz it's all about there's all kinds
of hookers and that's like the main
thing back then was hookers and drinking
there's like 250 bars in like a city
block and you know I made like $200
every two weeks and I always had money
yeah cuz it was like we'd go to like hop
happy hour or whatever in the morning
like Saturday morning at like T's tavern
or whatever it was on Gordon Avenue and
it was like nickel for a beer so I
really like learned by polishing like
drinking skills like the big time over
there and course it's a thousand degrees
out and it's just like so much fun
yeah when I my first after two years
you're just like okay come on you
actually you actually had enough of it
well I wanted to get on with you know I
got over you know I took my screen test
got orders to buds and was a alright and
back then now they got this big fucking
pipeline and all this
I flew in the Coronado on a Friday
Sunday we had our class up party which
is you shave your head there's a keg of
beer you get liquored up and then be
idiots and then Monday morning your
start is day one so you checked in on
Friday shaved your head on Sunday okay
one class stop on Monday that's it yep
here we go did you get rolled I got
rolled in the second phase which nobody
does I didn't get hurt
I just wouldn't leave my slim buddy what
happens my swim buddy I wouldn't leave
on a swim I'm like that tie on the cob
yeah well you can't leave your swim
buddy right and so what do you do yeah
you fail yeah and you just take it in
the shitter and then and then like the
next why what you know next class like I
was like me and bring the cheese man
he's dead now yeah we're like the top
three swim there's
my swim swim I failed to swim
yeah began so I go they bring us to the
first phase office and I'm standing
there with my swim buddy and they're
like all right and they there was a you
know ten or twelve or fifteen pairs
failed to swim so they're asking
everyone like they're calling us in the
office the first phase office by the
Bell so me and my swim buddy get called
in we're like number seven to get called
in I couldn't hear what everyone else
was saying but I didn't know what the
hell was going on I was just like scared
I wanted wanted to make it through this
training so we go in there and so
there's something called guiding which
is like the person that when you're
swimming in the open ocean you have to
it's basically steering but you call it
guiding for some reason you know you
guide so you make sure your swim in the
right direction so they go you know
YouTube next player get in here so we
walk in I'm standing the attention is it
what the hell happened to you too and my
swim buddy
points at me and goes Willing doesn't
know how to guide oh my god and I was
like and the guy was a slow swimmer like
that was the problem and he was that was
the problem yeah yeah and so I'm
standing there just going damn I just
got it's just got dining out for
something I didn't even do so I just
kept my mouth shut and I was like I'll
do better right and then what they did
was they split us up and they put us
with good swimmers
than the same thing like me meet my new
swim buddy
on the next swim came in like fifth or
seventh or something I wasn't gonna come
in first or second cuz I know not enough
that no cuz you got some of those
fuckers in there that are swimming like
17 knots yeah I know
yeah but this guy failed again you know
and it was like oh maybe it wasn't
willing guiding yeah screwed you over
but it was alright you know I just had
to wait four weeks five weeks got back
in and it was fine
then then and then you you graduated
buds were you good in the water when you
showed up at buds oh yeah yeah did you
grow up swimming in lakes now sure no
it's just something you got to do like
like how many how many times was I in
the woods with people in the teams we
were from you know New York Jacksonville
Florida or New York City or Chicago
they're like what the fuck what with man
it's dark like who would say that the
dark is dark good night fuck when you
think we're gonna do like go you know
just lunch we're gonna go on lunch and
Beach and you know an owl so it's that's
just one of those things you had to do
there's some people that don't do that
very well I know I had a guy in my class
like a super stud wrestler from Iowa but
he never went in the water
man dude he was my swim buddy in uh in
like the pool phase where they're doing
like the stuff in the pool with you yeah
well yeah I feel like even stuff on your
so we're doing buddy breathing and this
dude is taking the regulator and
breathing 47 breasts in a row giving it
back to me I'd take like a breath nab
him still he still popped to the surface
and yeah he didn't make it he didn't
make it cuz he would just freak out in
the water so yeah man I was lucky you
know up in Maine as a little kid went in
the water all the time
the water never freaked me out I just
don't know why and people out man but
that's that's the whole thing you have
to be competent in the water mmm like
when you're underneath the ship and your
D rigging and all that then everybody's
like right next to each other you
just like chords floating around God
people think like it's all you watch the
movies they go they say show them diving
then all of a sudden they show them
climbing this shit like well what about
all the shit in between if you're
missing like the biggest fucking portion
that's horrible you're under there is
everywhere and the guy's kicking you in
the mask
you gotta deal with that and it's just
it's just fucking something that's like
sinking to the bottom yeah I get you
down say why is the line there's all
this pressure going this way boy that
wasn't the plan we rehearsed this like
40 times you can't communicate a beefy
nothing it's all just thing yeah and
you're just after a while it's like
survival like you just got to not die
and then somehow it usually works out
next thing you know you drop the surface
and everything is easy then you got to
go back so it's not like it's what makes
the team's good I think what makes the
team's good is when you have to deal
with all that crap of whether it's going
over the beach just to do a land warfare
up but you come over the beach or you
know D rigging underwater or a combat
swimmer op or rigging the boats or
whatever when you add the water and it
just makes it it's all a real world ah
so much freaky no even in training it's
real world yeah because you can draw
them down yeah you can I mean but the
buds thing like yeah I didn't grow up
syrup and running of that stuff but the
other things I I didn't have a plan B
yeah that was easy for me I never even
thought about quitting anything no I
mean it was like why there's nothing
else to do yeah I mean everything else
is just garbage junk and like knew not
know I have to do this this is what I
have to do because it's like the best
yeah I I'd never thought about quitting
at all and it was weird I think I in my
class that was from the fleet and he was
I bet you don't want to court the fleet
dude it's you you've not want to go to
the fleet and blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah and he quit again yeah well
yeah and I just was like man really
we had these serial quitters that come
back and come back and
after a while you know give up like and
what's that the first you don't succeed
try try again
how many tryin quit no sense to being a
damn fool about it you know I just
didn't have a plan B you know mm-hm
did uh did you do any of the water stuff
when you were in Subic Bay did you did
any of the team guys show you like not
playing or any hole no not at all
I did I did dive though I got my like
okay there he goes god that's good cuz
diving like when you I've never done
that but when you go through like the
basic that do this do some kind of yeah
you do like Carly breathing but it's
like the big yeah the big beautiful
regular yeah okay then take your mask up
and then blow through yeah okay clear
your mask and but that's definitely
helpful but it was fun I mean it was
something to do besides drinking all the
time so I did that like one weekend and
then there was like yeah how long it
takes to get one of those qualifications
yeah you go some classes some pool and
then they take you in Subic like out to
flip flop island oh it's actually really
nice man yeah yeah man when I got the
little card remember you went through
buds and you get water if they had this
for you yeah they did yeah so I got
looking a little card that said I was
qualified like I could go rent diver
yeah and I don't know where that is I
lost it yeah fucking but when I had that
thing that thing I got that and I
thought I was them kind of a man you
know I was like you know what I would
look at it from you know be my wallet
look at it like you feel like you're a
Jesus kid yeah it's like I felt like I
was James Bond's like who cares not even
a thing anymore now not enough kind of
like when I got issued my first floppy
hat oh yeah I thought yeah well you
arrived yeah I'm ready to go to no no no
like that's like you say less I make I
thought I was going to be and I'm like
that day yeah I know but yeah I still
have my first floppy hat
oh I'll cost you two
just keep everything I don't I didn't
keep anything good you might need it one
day I kept my floppy hat I don't have a
shadow boy I have a shadow box that
someone made me like the good friends of
mine who used to do that living like
make coins made it for me it's part of
it it's like in my room somewhere it's a
not I don't know where any of my metals
are I just don't care yeah I'm like just
such a loser when it comes to that shit
one time I was in my son's room when he
was like maybe 7 or 8 no he's probably 9
or 10 years old and I'm like looking for
something I figured he took it and I'm
walking around who stole my yeah step on
something it's like sharp but I'm like
lot it's underneath a pile of my kids
clothes like I pull it out and it's like
a bunch of a bunch of my metals I don't
recommend we're not cool whatever
yeah lathe Leafs like they've said to me
man we never got you anything for tea
you Boosh I'm gonna get you something
he's been saying that for like 10 years
I think he's busy yeah yeah so that's
why I don't have him of any kind of
nothing the guys when I retired gave me
a big giant Trident that's like like
seven feet tall
oh really yeah I was have it in the
corner with all my weightlifting bars I
have it in there oh yeah yeah everyone's
well if I I feel like if I if someone
breaks into my house and I wound them
I'm gonna finish them off with that show
well yeah I would get it and just run it
put one of those things right through
their neck that yeah it'd be good
it could also spear him know like
through the midsection yeah and then
like get Thor you know and then you both
can like be a good picture all right so
you get done with buds no factor
whatever you show up at team one and did
you get put into a platoon immediately
yeah and it's now what 1989-1990 yeah so
is the gulf war on the horizon yet or
not Nelly
so Kuwait has not been invaded yet or it
has
been invaded we're not sure we're gonna
that happened August 6th and when did
you get to the team like December okay
so it took about nine months so you
showed up at the team there's no war
going on but I had to go through SBI
okay didn't have sqt back yeah that's
yeah I still basic in doc and they just
grabbed a bunch of guys and it was
actually really squared away at team one
yeah
creating clan warfare you did demo all
your weapons and shit patrolling tactics
we did maritime air you know rubber
ducks limp ducks all that shit there he
did photo Intel like all kinds of stuff
in field developing yeah yeah I'll just
talk to this camera guy up in Wyoming's
I told him I used to do that Wow but now
it's all like digital campaign to do any
of those like yeah of course spend hours
and hours doing that and then a lot of
shooting basic shooting you know shot
m14 til your friggin fingers go cuz you
were not a man if you didn't carry an
m14 well yeah because it was like the
best gun ever my bicep would get bruised
from shooting the m14 I am cuz and I
know people say well because it would
like move like you can't just keep it
there the whole time now it's like
gigantic and that's why the m14 god
bless his soul such a great weapon
remember how many malfunctions you had
with it yes I am a nun yeah ever and
actually I had one somebody else's shell
from an EM from an m16 went and like
went lodged somehow into my ejector port
well yeah in the middle of whatever yeah
it could happen yeah so that's one yeah
but yeah those things are freaking but
accurate they didn't they didn't survive
the how do I put it the rail system yes
once once everything started becoming
attachments and shit they tried to do it
and then the gun was like 360 pounds
yeah so it just it never really but back
then the m16 was basically a piece of
shit yeah
even the NR 727 the carpet Dean's that
whole evolution leading up to the m4
they got better and better and better
they are reliable and you know it just
makes sense on the battlefield if you
you got an m4 you got a you know five by
six you work with the Marines the army
you can always go anywhere and get some
more ammo say who has strip clip friggin
308 a.m. you know seven six to nobody
you know do you ink it up the 60 that
got to be a wicked pain in the ass was a
great gun I mean I still love the thing
you put that front sight on there mister
and yeah but as far as the night-vision
it didn't make the cut just yeah my take
about it you know yeah I still have one
that's still like my primary battle
rifle I looks great always gonna work a
hundred percent it's gonna work
I mean if shit goes down chaos in the
streets and you're like on a cul-de-sac
you could come out with that I mean I
have a fucking tommy gun is what I'd
have my fedora are on your ball you're
black and everybody but now you
fantasize about stuff you know I mean
it's just a it's a Tuesday afternoon
what are you gonna do I mean yeah tommy
gun fedora hat man I mean come on hey
you want to go to the bar and get
liquored up yeah yeah let me just grab
my tommy gun real quick black yeah
so SBI you go through you learn a bunch
of stuff I had s TT is what they called
it when I went through yeah and then
good dudes teaching us that stuff that
was great because you still get kind of
treated like shit but you're at you know
you weren't a new guy you weren't a bud
student you were yeah you were getting
treated like a little bit better than
the buds guy then did you get then you
got assigned to offal - yes sir I got
assigned to alpha platoon SEAL team one
and so in the old days alphabets who met
you were riding a boat yes so hard alpha
alpha I didn't care just no anything
you're just like wow yeah
whatever I'm in tune cool how many new
guys were in your first puts out we had
a few we had like cuz I used to stack
the art buttons with more new guys we
add I just wanted to fill that thing up
because no one wanted to do an arc flow
wow it you know new UI a manicure no no
that's what I'm saying
so it'd be like okay so just let's put
all the new guys in there yeah and let
them flow up but you get you had a
badass LP oh I did I did I had a an LPO
leanin petty officer who was one of my
buds instructors what was he like as a
buds instructor quiet and like
mean-looking like kinda like if you
don't do this
you're just a big pussy you know you
guys aren't putting out and just just
like because he was good at how does it
he was wicked he was good in everything
once he became my LP Oh like he was good
at shooting he was good at all water
stuff he grew up like somewhere in
California and kayak he could kayak he
was a really good skydiver yeah he was
just good at everything everything
mountaineering so respected yeah it's
freaking nice man yeah he's a great guy
I'm gonna actually see him here by the
time this podcast is probably I'm gonna
visit him somewhere in the country here
and but he did I think 20 years after
that as a state trooper damn yeah I
think was Alaska and pre sure but he's
just he thrived in that environment and
he was a good teacher like he'd take us
and go okay guys here's here's I do this
you're like 80% correct yeah this is the
20% that you suck at and then here's how
to get better at it you know they Roger
that I mean he was just and a good dude
the reason I know him is cuz when he got
back from that deployment he took over
CQC or CQB yeah at team one he was the
CQB instructor so he put me and my first
work up through CQB and he was the first
guy that I was looking at maybe not the
first guy but
he might have been he was the first guy
I was looking at going he's there's a
lot of going on here there's a lot like
yeah this isn't just a mechanical thing
of you're going through in your clearing
rooms like there's there's there's
thought happening here there's there's
intentional decisions being made like I
could see I could see that well the way
he would explain things I'd be thinking
okay he knows like some more a lot more
than oh yeah then a lot of us other guys
do yeah and he explains some little
detail and you'd say oh and he would
make sense to me you know I'd be
thinking wow that makes for water Suns
and yeah he'd say stuff like in you know
room combat shit he'd say well why are
you doing that like well we're done here
we're gonna go there well what about
deconfliction like what what do you mean
well you're not the only group within
your group assaulting this building or
the ship you make sure that the other
guys are alright yeah now the first one
actually exactly the kind of thing I'm
talking about when the blinders come on
in the teams everything's like went from
land warfare
you know CQC whatever you want to call
it no sky diving diving once the
blinders come off and the good the good
people in your life and the teams will
make the blinders come off and then
that's when you start growing as a
frogman because it's easy just go okay
ba ba you know but you have to you have
to do the basic shit so well and never
forget it but then open your mind up to
what's like shooting like front side
front side front side then you get
exposed to both eyes open
mm-hmm and your front set is blurry
because your targets clear because guess
well when you're shooting paper front
sight front sight front sight that's
great but when you're shooting people
you have to make sure you can shoot them
you have to look at their hands you
can't do that if the targets blurry
right so when you transition I mean that
really opens your eyes you do years and
years of front sight and then you start
opening your
and because you have to and then it all
goes away because you're on nods and you
got a laser and then you have to
transition because you might be noon you
may have to go assault this building I
remember we were doing a shipboard
movement on the pier side ship that we
used to use at the time so we're on that
ship we're doing just nasty gasps the
seagull shit all over the place but we
were doing we were like moving as we'd
come up the stern of the ship and then
just move as a big group a big screen
like a big and he just asked a question
you know like well what if someone's you
know shooting at you and and everyone
was kind of stumped like the older guys
in my platoon were kind of you know we'd
shoot back or just some dumb answer you
know like oh yeah we would shoot back
but meanwhile we all died because we're
all in the open on a rental ship yeah
and then he taught us you know how to do
the little bump yeah and and then I
realized oh oh so there's this isn't uh
this isn't a recipe it's not like it's
not like a recipe oh this is what you do
every time yeah you can know if that's
that was probably the guy that made me
start thinking oh there's different ways
to diiie is a guy who made me stuff
yeah there's different ways to do this
there's things that I need to actually
think about and I can't just
I can't just follow the the the the
thing that you've been taught one time
and that's how you do it
it's like no you actually need to think
and that was the first guy that I said
that I started to realize there's a lot
more going on than I was aware of
absolutely there's a lot more oh a lot
more yeah it's not just I mean he would
straight down at the range and shoot
head plates at 50 yards like on timer
you know with his pistol yeah beep ping
yeah over while we were eating lunch
he's just down there and add that 45 yes
wicked nice yeah
when no one had like really nice weapons
like that it was a good one so yeah so
that's an awesome LPO to have for your
first time around damn your old running
mate told me a story you guys were on a
bus somewhere on like Liberty and some
guy was running his mouth some fleet guy
was running his mouth and making a bunch
of noise he was all drunk and whatever
getting crazy and all of a sudden your
LPO just like put him in a chokehold and
put him to see as like hey nobody just
get a little nap in there you'd be all
set and what's crazy about that is no
one knew what a choke hold no one knew
what a sleeper hold was really he did
yeah and he's like knew how to do it
yeah yeah I know that I wouldn't be able
to slip and then die was it yeah he was
a bass man yeah still is he's a great
guy yeah freaking awesome anything else
that he so what was that first Platoon
like did you guys isn't hepa tune the
war kicked off while you're in that
planet yeah so august 1st through August
2nd of 1990 Saddam invaded Kuwait and
everything buh-buh-bah so they sent
platoons from the strand even though
they had forward-deployed to tunes which
guys were passed know every word and so
we were on the ark platoon we didn't
leave till April and that like
officially didn't end but everything was
done by the time we get there we didn't
do anything really the only the only
like real thing I did in that platoon
was like a ship boarding now the big 53
helicopters one went down or pulled off
the ship killed everybody and we we dove
on the bodies and put him up but I was
with that guy and you know he was like
yeah yeah here's how we'll do it
totally cool but that was it we didn't
get any gunfights or nothing which is
unfortunate it was like fuck
you know so we're on a ship most of the
time and in the Middle East we got off
we did training and summertime
deployment if you left in April yeah so
it was 1,000 degrees yeah I was terrible
and then you know you can't eat enough
and all you did was like lift weights
and and then wait to get back and then
so you get back from that moment you're
rolling through right into your next
book - yeah but I got that story about
that first one oh I'm gonna work up talk
about like attitude adjustments and
stuff I kind of fucked up some
infraction somewhere I I wasn't late I
just I didn't have something ready I
don't know what it was but my chief at
the time he's like oh yeah okay yeah you
fucked up and well Rodgers chief I I
didn't really know I fucked up I'm okay
so it's like 1,600 you know I don't know
if it was Friday no it was a weekday and
he goes up to the grinder with me wait
what's he gonna do it punch me cuz that
the team that's kind of like a you know
still the thing you know I wouldn't go
crying to HR or whatever that is we
don't have that it's just like I can
figure it out hit each other and be done
with it and go back to work
so he's got this bags big construction
garbage bag you know and it's filled
with a tangled up flutter board line huh
Jesus so for those you don't know a
flutter board line is this without
getting into the whole hydrographic
reconnaissance thing its parachute cord
you know wine and it's 500 yards worth
and it's tangled up like a motherfucker
he goes I want this in the morning
back on the flutter board geez which is
like a big fishing reel yeah it's
gigantic cord without that big it's
bigger than like a gigantic pizza that
you order that's that that's the
diameter yeah
whatever that is I don't know so I go
well this is perfect man I'll just you
know flake it out like a fishing line
thence plight cut it and splice it and
as he's walking away goes I'll know if
you cut it and splice it I'm like fuck
so you know I did that for a few minutes
and realized man that's gonna take all
fucking night so I went to the country
store I got like a six-pack of Budweiser
actually got like a 12-pack and I'm
sitting there and about 5 o'clock in the
morning I finished it yeah and I had
signed the flutter board and I put it
all and I put it on the Chiefs desk and
I sat in space you know with a couple of
beers that kind of like passed out about
6 o'clock six fifteen chief comes in and
he's like hey oh my god heels smack me
up but I go you bet all set chief he's
like Roger that good to go good to go we
got shit to do let's go
PT Roger good lesson one man yeah I own
take out some 550 cord like we're in a
half the life when it comes off the
spool because it does that cardboard one
n words to degrade their egos whoever
made that thing is committed a war is
just awful check so you come back from
that deployment after being at sea and
now you roll into your second platoon
yeah did you get any schools when you
came back no there's a second they were
already halfway through the workup so it
was just like I did all the stuff but I
didn't have any time to do anything oh
that's right because the arc platoons
were off cycle or off cycle so you're
gonna get tossed into some and you lucky
then you got tossed about and that was
already in their workup yeah yeah good
platoon you know wasn't much going on
back then like 92 93 something when in
92 came back nine you deployed to the
pie with that platoon
our job were to Guam Guam had just
started so that's where you deployed to
yeah
it was like nothing there I know well a
matter of fact it was right it was right
in the middle we we they were just
exiting so we couldn't actually deploy
there so we went to Guam
there was nothing in Guam I was because
my first deployment was to Guam and we
would like the first guys to go to Guam
a hundred percent like oh you are going
to Guam yeah and the guys that had
deployed to the PI before we were just
moping around the bear like I said I was
stationed there and then how was the
workup standard workup yeah bunch of
freaking humping around the desert yeah
like the forward leading edge of battle
we had some good guys in trade trading
that understood more about war than I
did that's four days oh yeah yeah but it
was you know there was not much to do
reflect back on for a lot of guys I guys
had to if the guys were dealing was
Vietnam guys and now well my first
Platoon my LP oh they were talking about
he was in Grenada yeah that's right
with damn knack with Team six and then
my second platoons chief was in Grenada
two with team six so I had some
redundancy in that like learning but
some of it was like no no it Nick crazy
though and that's like cuz I had my
platoon commander my second platoon was
also in Grenada yeah and are you talk
and everyone was you know that was sort
of the and actually I had my LPO in my
second platoon was in the first Gulf War
and actually did yeah gotten some
firefights and el-sissi yeah and so so
those guys it was like David knew the
unknown to us yeah you know and that was
a that's crazy that there was that
little combat experience and the team's
back then you know military well you
know the eighties yeah
and now you gonna seal platoon every
single literally every single unless you
are a brand new guy every single guy's
been on a combat deployment or seven
you're right or you know 50 or 50 or
whatever yeah they're just there's tons
of em that are numb to it they're like
we're gonna do this deployment now
that's like we're gonna go somewhere
where there's nothing going on there
right yeah because we always used to
have a saying like if you're in a
deployment and you're totally at war
that's great but if you're in a
deployment we're just drinking beer and
working out and doing exercises drink
beer work out do exercises do that for
the boys who can't do that yeah because
guess what its gonna come full fuckin
circle it always does you know but we're
fortunate we we had a I'm just fortunate
like the timeframe I was born totally I
mean from I know everything that
happened in the eighties in the world
and I went in the service and it was
still old-school and then the y2k like
actually let's let's you know I learned
about the Industrial Revolution in
school I mean really gives a fuck that
the the technology revolution cellphones
computers I mean it's a it's changed the
world yeah
not just the teams that everyday life
yeah and I mean that was weird too
because we got to see and 911 remember I
mean we got to the teams there was no
email of course not I mean there was no
email there's no computers no computers
there's no email so the copy machines
really so my deployments my first
deployment my platoon commander and the
assistant platoon commander had each had
a computer yeah and like no one knew
what they were doing it cool fearless
were you doing anything on it right it
was just not me
no there was no use for him whatsoever
and then you know you fast forward I
remember uh Microsoft Word or no wasn't
even Microsoft it was like some other
word processing program and then people
started doing what you're talking about
yeah printed gear list oh I had for me
executions right
and all that stuff I thought I was
here's a funny thing about that right
like when I went in a training like
after my seventh platoon they're like oh
yeah you're gonna be the LPO of this
platoon over up team five mm-hmm I'm
fast-forward a little bit but no no no
you've done enough you're going into
training like oh fuck so then it became
trade at and I was like pine corner
there yeah so I had to put all the land
warfare stuff on PowerPoint you know and
didn't like do it right you know
professional not just bad I never had
one minute of formal computer training
mm-hmm the Navy never gave me any I
never asked I just I don't know how to
turn on the PC like I had no idea on the
side yeah and then I I had to I taught
myself how to do it and PowerPoint okay
can you put PowerPoint on this the guy
comes over and does it and then I'm like
I asked a few questions and figured it
out what do you do you gotta figure it
out it's like fucking terrible I had a
lot of you know past midnight night
starting at zero six just going you know
and I could I could get up go to work do
the two mile swim go run six miles
whatever the fucking PT was throw my
body I run through the house eight
hundred times and go drink a thousand
beers and go to bed at midnight sleep
for hours and I'd be good to go
eight-hour day on the computer I can
barely make it home and am i kills me
it's terrible I don't know how to one of
these fuckers who sit in cubicles like
blow the brains out after like ten years
you know the business suit and they're
all i overweight and high blood pressure
like I totally can see it that's no way
for a human being you you have to get
out of the cubicle man oh my god I'm
like head-butting the mirror that's it
yeah beating the team's where you're at
a minimum you worked out in the morning
and at lunchtime you're gonna go like
for a run on the beach somewhere you're
gonna go
- or you're gonna go freakin do rope
climbs or something out lunch and and
that's just the way yeah like think
about the fact that when you go when
you're in the team - you keep you work
out every day every day like that's just
awesome right and if you're not working
out you're doing everything we do in the
teams is working out yeah yeah so wait
okay well I'm not gonna beat you - you
don't gonna fuck your PT I'm climbing
the ships all day yeah you know if that
ain't working I don't know what the fuck
is you know yeah yeah the sir you if
you're in one of those jobs where you
are staring at a computer all day long
or you're sitting inside all time you
got up
you've got to get up and move why
absolutely so back to your second
platoon or going what are we forward to
your science second platoon yeah
was there any major leadership lessons
that you learned in your second flute
and I didn't really ask you that
question about your first platoon when
you because I imagine your LPO must have
left such like not like a hey here's
four points on how to lead but you just
watched that guy well I just yeah that
made him that's well the cat you're
talking about I don't know how he was
like you oh I see
yeah we are talking about he's like just
do what that guy does dude i ne and
you're all set I I spent my whole career
trying to emulate that guy yeah
everything about him and I did a crappy
job but I did the best I could the best
I could you know but my second platoon I
don't know I we didn't like there was no
major like conflicts not even close - we
did some exercises we had a good time
tile in Australia gotten a lot of like
fire fights and you know I mean we
didn't kind of went by yeah and I had a
lot of fun and learned I learned I don't
know I improved on my my shooting skills
in your second platoon myself tuned not
a ton but a little bit and I'll get more
into that as we
but was alright doing a platoon is that
period of time period of platoons which
I did one deployment to Guam in that
time period but you could see what was
happening and what was happening was it
was a pretty cookie cutter thing like
you're gonna do your work up you're
gonna go under to Guam you're gonna do
some exercises you're gonna come home
and you're gonna do that again that's
actually why I went and did a couple
arcs because it seemed like different
yeah they had a little better chance it
seemed of doing something real and
that's why I did a couple arcs with a
couple other guys but uh but yeah it
seemed like it's kind of cookie cutter
hey you're gonna do your work up you can
do put in your learning stuff you're
getting better at it but that's about it
that is exactly about it and now that I
look back at it some of the people who
were in charge of me you know what are
they oh I see Zell peels of cheese it
hindsight's 20/20 but they didn't really
do me any favors they didn't have a lot
of forward thinking and I hate to say it
but Sullivan like wow let's just get
through this deployment and I get
through it this is like my whole life
like I don't care if I ever go home you
know this is what I do this is our
profession you know and and I would hold
some ammon animosity towards them
they're piss me off basically did it
seem to you like it seemed to me well as
we did from what you just said I think
that there were some guys in the teams
at that time period that worth not
thinking at all that we were going to
war and no no no no no no it was just
not I want to do this so they could
punch that ticket to make rank yeah but
they were they were not thinking hey
there's a war on the horizon hey we need
to be ready for combat we need to
improve our skills there was definitely
guys in the teams in the 90s that were
just you know there were some great guys
too obviously but there was plenty of
guys that were hey yep we're gonna go on
this appointment this is what I have to
do hey stay out of trouble all right
yeah
we gonna send a pretty extra training no
no no we'll just train if we don't have
to Train we won't like well yeah because
if you don't make us train we're gonna
go train out in the Boz yeah
I'm getting big fistfights and break
chairs over people head and get in
trouble which I don't know why you get
in trouble I still think like oh yeah
okay
Oh bar play yeah don't do it again
I never got anybody trouble for that
like yeah cool no don't no stick don't
be disrespectful to the cops but you
know come on you want rock guys up on an
island for six months yeah and then go
oh you know go home and you know what
no not we're not jobs that's what
taxpayers pay us board if he wild and
crazy so when all that happens were like
right at all that's what that's what we
do so that so that platoon you do you do
it's cookie cutter well and then your
next book your next platoon after that
were you the LPO I'm an expert after
that you did another platoon well the
second platoon I gave up the machine-gun
now I did that wampa tune and then I
became a point man okay that's what kind
of one I was one hey that kind of takes
the blinders off mm-hmm and I became a
point man was I the best point man
no was I the best at anything in the
teams no ever in the history of ever
nothing but I was decent point man I'd
say it was average and I did that for
the next five buttons unless I was in a
leadership position oh I did my third
Platoon was a point man wait your second
platoon was appointment or second yeah
okay so you gave up machine gun after
your first Platoon yeah and now your
second platoon point man third Platoon
point man yeah which means you're
getting really good at the land nav yeah
and we didn't have GPS GPS and your pace
count is on 7,000 yards in my head not a
count or nothing just
yep Roger mmm-hmm
you know and I got real good I was
pretty good at laying I'm anyway but
when did you go to Sniper school my
third put them so in your third Platoon
work up you go to Sniper school which
Sniper school was it an nsw sniper yeah
at the time yeah I must have been in one
of the early ones yeah it was not not
the earliest one so it was squared away
it was awesome and we did like a couple
days of classes and then we went up to
KO'ing to california and that's when my
shooting my long gun shooting just
became insane oh yeah for silver so all
right you know Sniper school you know
where's my cool sniper weapons no iron
sight m14 for like two weeks straight at
a thousand inches so after a while this
is your group the size of a quarter
twenty rounds this is your group and
then you start shooting for distance
calling wind still with iron sights iron
sights art sighs finally they break you
into the scope when they start teaching
you how to you know mills how to range
targets they didn't have lately raid
your laser rangefinders and so when you
finally get all that stuff i mean you're
such a good shooter i got our sniper
school and my platoon we did a pistol
shoot me and my shooting buddy
you know z they're not z but that's his
initial zga we smoked everybody just
because we could shoot mmm and they just
go back from like rogers like yeah yeah
but and that really really like i became
a really good long gun shooter like
awesome
yeah i've been shooting archery and man
the laser rangefinder they're freaking
crazy oh my god they're the best they
probably taken everything they're crazy
yeah I mean I bought one
I'll take almonds gonna buy one guy like
he's like I'm like which one's the best
one there this one and I was like okay
cool
it's compensating for angle and just
real quick I was two weeks ago two and a
half weeks ago I was in ro range
sir they call it but it's a Range Safety
Officer at the Wyoming ripe ripe old
tactical championship up in Wyoming some
of these rangefinders these guys that
are like incredible and a shout out to
them guys there are some of the best
shooters I've ever seen in my life
like in the world good with the
competition it's called the Wyoming wrt
see Wyoming rifle tactical championship
or or WT RC I can't remember excuse me
if I fuck it up that's just who I am but
it's also a fundraiser for Special
Operations wounded warriors some of the
best people on the planet man awesome
but some of the care was like holy fuck
you know but I had this back in the day
that it saved me like I don't know seven
hundred hours of horse shit in my life
you know but yeah times but yeah I
became a really good shot this
rangefinder I have as a stabilizer on it
to look oh so you're not like shaking
and the only thing it doesn't do is like
pull the trigger give you a blowjob and
shoot the gun for you I mean it's it's
like crazy yeah yeah so you cert so
that's when you went to Sniper school
you did that that Sniper school was the
NSW with the stalking and all hi yeah
yeah I was hot
it wasn't easy it wasn't easy at all how
many people graduated that school I I
can't remember there was I was in like
the like the top cat but I think we had
a 10 mm maybe 15 man NSW came out of the
gate hardcore on that school yeah yeah
they did like that NSW Sniper school
it's loose yeah freaking legit yeah it's
not easy yeah but I like I loved it I
mean I thought it was awesome so then
you go on deployment with that where'd
you guys another qualm deployment yeah
it wasn't there's another insignificant
not that it wasn't great and everything
but it was no yeah yeah I mean that's
what people have to understand in the
90s it was like you're going on
deployment
we're on standby for whatever praying
everyday that a major theater war would
break out yeah yeah absolutely I mean
just hoping but one thing we did do is
we I'm sorry I got a backtrack one
platoon we were in Australia working
with the SAS and shooting the shit and
we were we were doing some training or
doing some shooting our guys were doing
really well
like shooting wise and of course with
those cats who are awesome you're like
the best guys out there you know just
like a bunch of special forces around
the world their best guys ever like oh
yeah you guys man you're shooting the
shit out of it mate and he goes wow it's
easy for you and I'm like the fuck you
talking about you guys grow up playing
freaking cowboys and army and and a mic
and I never really thought of it he goes
you know back then they're like we don't
have guns here they like don't have guns
unless you've got a special permit to
hunt or you're joining the military or
the cops we're gonna grow up doing that
damn you know I'm like I never thought
of it you know that Christ BB gun Wars
and your kids and your heart you know
just throwing rocks yeah that's have a
rock fight what you know so anyone yeah
you don't think too much about the fact
that many of the people that come into
the teams or into in the military they
grew up with a rifle oh yeah it's
comfortable around god yeah I mean I
don't see any reason to be afraid of a
gun no unless you're an idiot yeah and
you should be afraid of it yeah because
you can shoot yourself great but that
and then my third Platoon we like so we
didn't I don't seize did some stop yeah
just you know like him but people don't
realize in them years when there was no
Wars going on we did some like
ridiculous training stuff no yeah okay
we're gonna do like this three miles
swim and then put your gear on and hump
you know walk like I don't know here to
Saskatchewan
then and then you get a five-minute
break and then you got to shoot like 17
rounds in 2 seconds and like really I
mean how skinny do you want me to be you
know I do like 5 mile swim like 10 mile
run and 2 mile swim like dude it takes
all day you know doing the Monster Mash
is that Friday I mean they were fun yeah
they were fun but yeah they're and
that's the other thing is I have
occasionally people asked me they say
something along the lines of I was in
the Marine Corps I was in the Army I was
in the Navy during the 90s and didn't do
anything and I feel like I didn't do a
good job serving my country knows it
look man
he served because you did what your
country needed you to do and when it
when it was 1994 or 1996 and you and the
SEAL Teams and the Navy needed you to
deploy to wherever and you'd go do an
exercise with some country like that's
what you did and and we trained and we
did we did establish and maintain
standard operating procedures so all
these little things that we do you know
like they came out they they somebody
had to carry the thread of being able to
do this stuff all right
for during these time periods and that's
what that's what we were doing you know
making sure that this thread making sure
that the knowledge at least at a minimum
level stayed in place
yeah and a lot of a lot of it it's not
even the tactics and stuff it's the I
don't know
and there's still teams I think the
world the word like phrase old school
has to always be there it has to yeah
like just BT app through everything
that's not an old-school thing just just
that attitude like you got a at least
every day and a seal platoon still true
salt team whatever you're talking about
someone's got to be like don't be a
fucking pussy just do it and shut the
fuck up
yeah because if it ain't like that and
the most exclusive man's club ever then
then with what do you got you got a you
got nothing
yeah there's definitely you definitely
have to maintain that attitude of hey
we're gonna do we're gonna do we're
gonna we're gonna get this done oh yeah
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
get this done and it's like cool man
this is gonna really suck yes things
that are gonna suck real bad cuz if you
don't do it even if you're operating
here in platoon or whatever you're doing
if you're not doing a gut check like a
serious gut check every two months or so
something's wrong mm-hmm it shouldn't be
easy no it shouldn't it should be like
fuck this gonna suck but then when
you're doing it it's it sucks so bad
it's fun yeah cuz you what your chums
you like yeah whatever it looks good no
one no one ever says anything about it
you just like yeah cuz you go cuz you
think about some of these things that
you do you get into you jump you jump
into the ocean with a zodiac and then
you get in the zodiac and you rig it and
it's freezing and you're in a wetsuit
that's cold and now you drive from over
the horizon so it's 15 or 20 miles of
driving in a zodiac against this well
against the swells you're getting beat
up your ass is chafed you're the guy
next to yous puking and and what you're
doing is you're getting to a harbor
somewhere so you can then put on your do
the real take your dive rig out of a kit
bag yeah do a like a cursory check on
your dive rig to see if it got damaged
on the jump and then you put that thing
on your freaking it's all awkward huge
and and then you roll into the water and
then you're underwater for three and a
half hours next to some idiot who
doesn't know where he is and you're
freezing when you get in the water
you're freezing your hope nap you you're
actually happy when you get the water
cuz then you know you're gonna warm up
in like two minutes cuz gonna be kicking
and then you get done with that you come
back out you've got you turn on a spy or
strobe or a higher are strobe somebody's
a white stroke because no one's out
there no there's no enemy gonna see you
because you're in the middle of the
ocean
yeah did you get picked up climb back in
your totally exhausted you have one of
those collapsible canteen like the to
court a theme is in the bottom of your
kit bag you pull that thing out you
drink some of that I pull it out it got
punctured yeah so I just like I just go
I got nothing and then you've got to
drive another 15 miles back over the
horizon yeah and and about you have
about seven miles left the Sun starts
coming up yeah and then you get there
and then you get loaded into some some
LCU that was beating you out there so
that's the kind of Dalia like that's
just that just sucks man yeah yeah used
to know all right so that's your so your
third Platoon your fourth platoon what
about your fifth platoon my fourth no my
fourth platoon
I was LP oh there you go you're a second
class LP I'll just think about that for
those who don't know what that means
you're the second class Petty Officer
alive LPS are usually supposed to be
first classes and now everyone in a
platoon is like a first class right back
in those days
man no is III z4z 5s in it and then
you'd have an LP oh but you were the LPO
as an e5 yeah how was that I loved it
you know my chief was a senior chief and
uh God rest his soul
my key ankle died TV is back but uh he
was one of the they talked about a nice
guy a super nice guy he was like so much
fun
he had that Texas drawl like from ah we
think well do this shit Tony he's just
funny you know but we had a great
platoon we again we didn't we didn't
really do anything
no made no were like being like actually
in charge I loved it I loved it I had a
pretty good oh I see and a oh I see and
we worked together we didn't I wasn't
I'm like
this is how I think we should do it but
you know let me know and there was a
couple east sixes in the platoon - they
were newer guys so they didn't oh oh so
you were to e5 LPO ranking bossing
around or whatever in charge of guys
that were senior to you on paper because
they'd come salute or something like
that and no big deal no big deal
team guys team yeah we figured it out
but once again we we did a lot of
drinking and fighting and didn't you
knock out one of your guys or something
yeah that's just
let's just stop that happens when I put
tuned I mean I got yelled at by the XO
and I'm like yeah whatever like I don't
you know he was like don't do that to my
guy okay but we didn't we ran out in
town the cops didn't get involved or
anything we just kind of like whatever I
swept it on the table I was like in the
office I got I'll do it again right now
and he's like no no no no I don't care
but you know it was all right then I'll
have team one after that not cuz I had
to but I transferred to SEAL Team 5
after that and at that time SEAL Team 5
seemed like a lot oh it seemed like it
had a little less stringent oh my god it
was the Wild West it was a it was 300
feet down the street and it was like
going you know going to the Wild West
and I'll say this about team five-man at
that time in the 90s they were full of
characters I mean fucking characters
yeah I show up recorders the first
morning I mean my starch Kami's with my
haircut my you could shave in my jungle
boots you know steam one and because
that's the right team or less yep the
quarters is like 7:20 I'm standing there
I'm the only guy on the grinder and it's
like seven sixteen and then the back
gate opens it's like coming out of the
Drew Carey Show back in the eighties
like guys aren't skateboards nobody's
wearing a uniform
give a fuck and they're like hey what's
going on yeah Bob a pile what do we go
through PT today I don't know who cares
just go run and I don't know hit the gym
like what the fuck is going on here
everything was loose everybody was
wicked cool so I'm like but then when I
started working with everybody the
square ons was there and the training
department in the platoons they just
proved that you don't need to be like so
Uniform Standards me that and still be
good operator I mean those guys were the
best I loved being at SEAL Team 5 I love
being at all my teams but you know that
was that was fun yeah there was a bunch
of guys that migrated from team one down
just oh absolutely
so I got in a platoon there and it was
another Arg
so this was my fifth platoon and I did
it hard but we had a great and did they
make you the LPO oh no no I did three
more platoons not being Yelp ill after
the item yeah that's kind of an
interesting deal I kind of knew how to
run still an e5 yeah so we did the Argan
and we uh we went overseas again we did
like some watch and Kuwait and they
still had that thing where guys are
doing is are or whatever but nothing
major and we didn't do anything but uh
it sucked like goes on another art and I
was like man this is this is fucked up
I'm like I'm getting on the I
I just reinvested I went over like ten
years so I'm like okay I'm committed for
twenty now you know you know he can only
work out so much and you know we drink
so much
it's getting stagnant but when I came
back they had this that the cap the
command advancement program so there's
52 e fives at SEAL Team 5 and what
they'll do is they'll just instead of
taking a test they'll just make you an
e6 and you get paid right away it was a
big it's kind of a big thing so out of
52 e fives I was ranked number one so I
got the cap so when TD was the CEO I
walked in there and we were talking and
it was between me and diamond god bless
my brother diamond he died last year and
I go fuck you you give it to Diamond
he's got a wife and kid I'll get it next
year or I won't ever get it so diamond
got it and I was like yeah and he bought
the beer so what's the difference so it
was all good to go but I was like I
don't care about rank I never did so I
did that and you know I thought it was
cool that is that's awesome what uh did
you get cap the next year yes sir I did
they used to tell me that I got capped
my whole career cuz I did got capped it
because I got captain five and then I
got captain Singh now perfect right
because you went in the program yeah
yeah but that that aquatune we did we
had a grape tune like one two three four
of those guys if not with us anymore
and not one of them is from a combat
thing hmm you know natural causes or
self-inflicted you know but it was a
good news a great tune we had a lot of
fun we had a lot of terrible times but
you know you have terrible times but
they're fun whenever fun man that just
are having fun so that platoon my Opie
oh I don't know still in BH I don't know
he was awesome he
he was great my I had two chiefs in
neptune one like gave up or got fired or
something and all this time I had chief
said gave me some good advice like my
third Platoon JH was the chief he was in
buzz with me he was a higher rank mm-hmm
so he had kind of a tough go at it when
he got to the teams and but he turned
out to be one of my best platoon geez
he was smart particularly you know and
he was cool too you know just he didn't
offer me a lot of advice tactically cuz
we kind of grew up at the same time so
it was you know we're both same level
but he was good with the Navy like he
told me this and that taught me shit
that I forgot but it was good to know
you know but a lot of the examples I
used as a platoon chief that I drew on
were mostly bad I'd have to say you know
51% of them were what not to do and you
were looking at him at the time saying
no that's not a good move are we looking
at or did you figure out later that
chief wasn't doing a good thing I
remember doing one thing we're doing
this crazy shit boring thing and I'm
like yeah let's do it again I can you
know we're not there yet we're not good
at it and my chief was like well yeah
the confident guys are gonna say that my
what the fuck what now all of a sudden
there's two groups like the confident
the non-cut we're fucking frogman what
do you what do you mean on confident
what is that
okay I'm them that way when I look at a
fucking computer or something but like
in the team's who's not confident yeah
like yeah okay I'm never gonna say that
ever in the history of ever like ever
ever yeah so then so then at what point
did you go into training oh I still have
a couple tunes to go here damn bro so
your fifth platoon was the article tune
yeah
you step down from L where you you know
not the LPO right so now you do your six
platoon yeah and what are you doing to
the sex between appointment again blame
an error at point
and airwrap yep and that was a spec ops
deployment at Guam yep
hammered it out get to work out Doug get
a workup done yep land warfare CQC yep
long humps in the desert yeah
owari oh yeah big time
by then I knew nylons so well like it
was like yeah okay yeah I'm the point
man I'm like yeah this is ridiculous I'm
like hey you know what chief why don't
you just let me carry the machine gun
he's like why cuz what the machine gotta
be the point man let's mix it up mmm
he's like oh dude cool you know the guys
like well that was another uneventful
year and a half two years ago when did
you make so then G what about your 7th
platoon well I made each six in my 6th
platoon to you so I was in East six in
my seventh platoon but I was in the LPO
again I was I was the Ordnance rep I
went back to ordnance or a point man you
just keep rolling
yeah just keep rolling dead keep rolling
yep and after that one another that was
a heart Bravo though we actually oh yeah
yeah but yeah we spent like 30 days on
the ship uh-huh like Korea or something
terrible I remember that because I
watched the subway series on the ship
back then when the Mets were playing in
okay like right
we ended in 2000 maybe 99 mm so you're a
first-class at this point yeah it then
you get sent to trader I get sent to
training sell at trading sell a team fun
and after like couple of months you did
your platoon LPO
and then you did four more deployments
yeah before I was a chief and then you
then you got to sign a training cell
yeah and they take training cell and
they group it all together and to trade
that right so I did like a year in trade
training cell at five okay and then when
I got orders to trade at most for three
years I'm like wait a minute I
did a year in training like yeah we
don't give a shit Michael fuck so we
stood up trade at and I was the LPO of
land warfare the whole time I was there
mm-hmm and during that I did get in
another school though I went to New
Zealand to the tracking course oh damn
so I learned how to track humans over
there I was it was a awesome like not
easy course meant a lot of really good
cats from around the world and had a lot
of fun when did how long had you been a
trade out when September 11th happened
I'm not sure maybe six months six months
and then what what did you just freak
out come no I went to you Zeeland
everybody else went to Afghanistan I
went to New Zealand as I had along with
that course seven weeks so you get done
with that and now you're freaking out
well cosig am so i come back from that
and alright what am i going well okay
you're gonna go you're gonna go and then
like I didn't I just kept working at an
island working working working and then
when Iraq kicked off one of my old
master Chiefs like I need a guy so he
took me and sent me overseas and that's
when you were there yeah no Rach this is
when yeah you relieved us right so we
should we did like a little turnover
when I was working with the poles yeah
but we were working with the poles so
right yeah so you came in to kind of
take over the liaison right exactly as
it was and then which was a good job huh
it was great you must have been stoked
so I was I was in Baghdad I was an al
Asad I was in Mosul I was back and forth
to Bahrain I really I was like the in
theater guy if you wanted something done
I mean I was walking through these
foreign airports with couple bags full
of machine guns
and just going to like the Brits or
whatever country had a plane ate their
way we can't do that way yeah here
here's a bottle of scotch I mean that's
how you got shit done and then all of a
sudden I show up in like Basra and like
okay I got to do this for a while and
then I'd be like all right yeah I'm
gonna go to Mosel get a flight there
from bribing people with stop and no
orders and you know you think it's like
will we get your orders and you wait for
your plane now it wasn't like that you
just gotta fend for yourself and I loved
it it was awesome then you did that
phone and I made cheap on that
deployment that's when you made chief
yeah I squeaked under the thing I had
like 19 years and day or 18 and a half
whatever and then when when did you find
out you were gonna go to team three
all right after I met you yep
cuz uh the guy we were talking about
calming his off cos I got you a platoon
a team three I'm Roger that
perfect were you ever worried you
weren't gonna make chief and you'd get
no no you figured it would work out yeah
it would always work out I would make it
work out I'd strangle someone before I
didn't you know it would just it would
just work out bodies would disappear
whatever I don't care
no I I don't take this and I'd be like
all right here's what's gonna happen
you know your signatures gonna be on
there or your blood you know it's one of
the other it's gonna fucking happen and
that's it not I've been not been doing
this my whole life just like okay little
retired go sit over the corner like ya
know I'm not gonna do it and then so
then you showed up a team three I show
up a team three and there's two asking a
bruiser
we talked about that on the we talked
about in the last one but gotta
reiterate that was so funny like who's
this will link guy in a Mike who Oh
Jocko like no it says John will link
Willie I'm like no I don't really know
I'm kind of no I'm and I'm walking away
like don't worry we're good to go we're
all set we're all set jump they like
naba you know the officers like well
what's he like I'm like he's good to go
that's all you need to know just stand
the fuck by don't have any fuckin me I
don't care I didn't know you my whole
life I'm a yeah whatever I don't have
any like loose ends and they're just
like now officers are they like I'm like
what do you mean I mean no fucking loose
ends because he's gonna he's like a
shack in the water I could smell blood
he'll go oh really he can't show up with
a proper uniform and they're just like
really what does he like uniform nazi or
whatever you know and like no he's just
like do it right I can go I go here's an
idea if you do say hey what do you think
about this Jocko to go he'd look at you
ago well I thought about like doing it
like good not like what you're saying
that's just junk and they're like yeah
then you meet everybody
yeah you know that was uh that was good
buddy yeah that was a good time you
could tell almost immediately like that
we were gonna have a good time
oh I know I know everyone was kind of
there everyone was kind of in the game
and yeah you could tell pretty quick
we're gonna have a good time and the
very first thing we did was land warfare
which is as it should be
there's a little bit of luck involved
with training you get to do first but
you know we got lucky you might fly or
someone move the freakin things on the
boards over a tray that to make us have
land warfare first but we had land
warfare firsts you know there's a lot of
guys team guys listen to podcasts away
we should shit here and I gotta think
that they're like yeah we did this
forest I remember if we did that Perot
so like I remember everything like
everything
but not everything you know what I mean
like if you say we might um that woods
down there in Florida wrote a wrote a
book he's got a memory cuz I'm like how
the fuck did you remember that and he's
like I used to write stuff down now I
had a wheel book just like you did and I
would write stuff down and I go back I
still have them they make no sense Marco
says it says I got grid coordinates then
I got a leg line through it and it says
other fucking grid and then roll over
next day get get guns like what yeah
would you have to write that down mine
are like that too I have from when we
were in Ramadi I have three like I
forget what size they are but maybe
maybe eight by six or something they fit
in your cargo pocket right and I carried
it all the time and so I've got all
these little boxes with wards next to
him and I can kinda remember what some
one thing that's cool is when I would
sit through a mission brief I would
write my notes down that I was gonna say
to everyone so I have like mission you
know 134 it says you know tell them the
watch you know it says watch that road
this building is a threat and don't
forget to check in with this ECP I don't
like this just like random stuff that
was simple super at a time and super
emphasize the rules of engagement yeah
yeah of course I always did that I
thought that was great yeah but so I
have these kind of like random notes and
what sucks is Lafe had the whole hard
drive of every opt that we did and it
was classified secret obviously and it
was classified secret for no good reason
but you know when we we had to turn it
in and they took it and it's destroyed
or whatever but that had every op every
planning I mean everything was on that
and yeah that's good the notebooks I
have are like your notebooks it's like
some random grid coordinate some random
execution checklist for lines and I'm
like
I'll rearrange this yeah it's like so
many they can't remember like all the
shit you know I look at the notebooks
and usually the not a mo more like full
summer like three quarters then I lost
it in a pair of bag forever I just get
another one and be like I'd write this
down like and I'm thinking why am I
writing this down like at what point
like in the middle of the night when I'm
on nods and I'm in a gunfight I'm gonna
pull this notebook out go oh yeah you
know I'm just gonna beat you up to
someplace where there's nobody shoot at
me and then I like figure it out yeah
yeah yeah that's why I would be I wrote
down the notes that I wrote down were
all notes that I wrote down so that I
was gonna tell you guys yeah like every
every note I have is a note to you guys
I mean very I guess maybe there's a
third of them that are notes to me that
say like hey tell the CEO bla bla bla or
tell the brigade commander that you know
the guys are gonna be over here like so
there's some notes like that but I don't
have any notes that say I felt I felt
good about this operation and I you know
I have a course not I never any of that
I don't have any of that I don't like
like when I actually did sleep I would
like all right my guns good okay I'd lay
down and I would sleep like a baby for
those hours whatever I slept so good in
a war zone number one you're like wicked
tired number two it's simple it's not
like life you get up every day okay
here's we're gonna do that's fine and go
back mom oh and get up mmm easy mm-hmm
no like regular life shit there's
there's there's definitely the op tempo
of there's just you constantly have the
next thing that you're like there's no
you never finish on a deployment you you
think you don't finish the day the day
just rolls into the next day into the
next day to the next day
so you're just on this this amped up
cycle of what are we gonna do next
what's going on and it
this doesn't stop so when you when you
when you have a chance to lay down your
comm oh yeah it done there's a picture
of me and Dave Burke that steeled yeah
yeah nice reaction time but it's me and
him I'm pretty sure it's cop Falcon and
you know he's the commander of salt 6
and I'm the commander of tasking a
bruiser and we're up on this rooftop and
we're both asleep it's probably about 10
o'clock in the morning
and it's funny but I was thinking like
by the time I would get into the field
I'd be so tired and you know and that'd
be the first time we're like okay cool
everyone's on security and I'm gonna go
to sleep right now and it's Dave Burke
and me sit on a rooftop racked out just
done and just need three hours of sleep
I remember that one deployment that one
I was up on this building and I had a
300 mag and I was looking through this
thing and for some reason that little
section it was just me we didn't have
enough people for the whole building
whatever so that's fine I could crawl
and meet up with the other guys then go
downstairs no big deal it was like
August and I'm like fuck I don't have
any water I don't have any shade nothing
but I have to stay on the job so now I
realized this about 9:00 in the morning
so the Sun Goes Down at like 9:00 at
night and I go okay yeah I'm breaking my
shit down I'm kind of so this is after
you've been sitting there for 14 hours
yeah and you have a crawl back give zero
fucking water in your system it's like
nothing it's like a hundred and twenty
degrees so I'm like I break out my
silver Ranger I look because I know
what's going on
my lips are is white as this piece of
paper like just like that chunks some
like going I'm peeling it off my
like you know I'll be fine but I
literally got like three hours to like
die all right
so I don't say a fucking thing cuz I
want to be a pussy you know but I know I
got some cokes or something and woman
come to you you know I finally I get
that like because my throat's like this
big you know there's like nothing
there's no airway so put my rock on
where exfil and out of the building at
night you know and say you know I'm like
looking down holding my field of fire
you know and I'm the chief so I should
be smarter than that but I'm like my
vision starts to narrow because I like
and I'm like I can snap out of it and
I'm like now I'm good to go I get back
and after like an hour back at the cam
like oh shit I had to drink some water
you don't out drank like four quarts of
water like in like six hours later I was
pissing like blue you know still I don't
think you really come back from a
dehydration like that but it's all those
years is like drinking and that just
conditions you so when it's you know
Nilan so when you get into that spot
it's not so bad like I'm not gonna die
wicked clothes no no seriously like in
fact you know feeling your dizziness and
then you just go and it goes away for a
while then it comes back cuz you can't
out you can't outrun your body you like
you know I mean you have the dehydration
will get you yeah it's it's crazy how
the man you see guys that eats you guys
at the desert training they'd go they'd
go tits up pretty much if we were doing
when I was a trader if if it was summer
and we were doing like a 8 6 to 8 click
insert
by the time extract was going down
there's a decent chance someone was
going down
yeah for real yeah and and you're
talking about completely sober usually
hydrated usually like awkward answer why
is it that it was usually on the insert
because you're just coming out of the
damn air conditioning because that's now
that I think about it was almost always
on the insert well one of the things I
instituted and and if I'm wrong about
this somebody correct me but I think I
was the first guy to do it was we doing
immediate action drills I would walk the
guys out I did it
fucking thousands of those and I would
pre plan a guy and you kind of could
tell like we're not gonna shoot back
towards the canal kind of shit but a guy
who's on the right flank if it was
perpendicular parallel whatever it was
or the point man they would just fall
down with nothing just fall down and
like way their guys would be like
contact right you know order they start
shooting and they drag the wounded guy
and like okay and then comebacks with it
and usually they did a good job you know
like so what happened well you know we
took contact this guy went down by the
bar no you didn't the guy just fell down
well what do you mean I'm like well
maybe it was a heat casualty mm-hmm and
not to be a date yeah kinda to be a
danger a little bit that's how you teach
the less it's like you know so how do
you differentiate maybe gets taken out
by someone you don't here's a shot well
what are you shooting at you know
there's no real good answer
did you try to take the blinders off
yeah I also say that's one of those
things what you're actually teaching is
like you actually have to think about
what's happening oh absolutely
even an immediate action drill like okay
there's an immediate action drill but
you better be you better think about
what's actually going on because the the
answers aren't what's the word the
answers aren't just a rote memory no
there's no answer it's all hectic
garbage you got to decipher and figure
out and the only thing that comes close
to it in the civilian world is
yeah Elkanah this last past year a
killing this gigantic bull elk me and
two team guys were there was five team
guys there in Wyoming and when I when I
killed my big bull it was like the other
two guys couldn't carry a gun because
they'd already limited out they tagged
out and so we ran it just like an OP and
we have you know little PLO take off
hand arm signal comes up and guys are my
Chum crass is like okay this big bull
Elks going from here to here and it was
so intense and I tell this to my chums
like I mean I've actually shot some guy
in the war whatever you know like
yawning hmm
hunting Alcon like this they're so like
big and majestic and beautiful and like
they will kill you in a minute
and they don't care about you they're
just like it's like life on steroids
it's so unbelievable I highly recommend
that if you like hunting you hunt help
because it's there screaming you're not
in a rut and they're battling each other
you can hear the times and then the big
bull comes out fucking incredible I'm
going in September it's unbelievable
with a bow it's I'm never I'm not a bow
hunter Yeah right I don't know where
you're going you're gonna Idaho going to
Utah Utah yeah yeah to a to a place that
guy went to high school bow hunts in
Utah he's from this the hunt that I'm
going on I'm going with this because I
take up it's like the the best possible
part like Andy Andy stump he said that
this hon he's at yeah he's like this hon
is gonna spoil you because it's the best
part I love that and even these good
guys taking John Dudley he's you know a
world-famous bow hunter and Archer and
he's like yeah it's good
this is as good as it gets like just the
spot where I'm going as good as it gets
oh shoot it's frickin
it's it's so badass yeah you know and I
went home back to New Hampshire because
it was in October season back to New
Hampshire hunted I hunt with these guys
up at a camp they're just like the best
everybody's like a character killed a
deer this year you know but it's not
like that it's it's you know one thing
well so this guy John Dudley was asking
me he's like it seems like this would be
good for guys to get into oh my god I'm
like yeah and for me so we just did this
3d archery challenge up in Montana and
when we're up there look it's an it's an
admin thing basically like you're
walking through the woods and then they
go okay there's the target and then you
you shoot the target they're anywhere
between 30 and maybe 120 yards with a
bow which is far shots but for me I was
telling him I'm like you know when I was
younger in the teams we would patrol
around the woods yeah and that's what
you're doing you're patrolling on the
wood you're trying to be quiet like
that's a skill that and the wind yeah
the wind and but like even in the desert
it's different than like when I was when
I was when we would go to Fort Lewis
Washington or we'd go to Fort Chaffee
Arkansas or like we go down to pant you
ever go to one of the training trips to
Panama huh
so like patrolling through the woods but
then I might not Panama City Panama
no panner oh yeah yeah jungle it's so
crazy you get that that that skill of
walking quietly through the woods and
looking at someone else and doing all
hand signals and not and I was saying
this to John I'm like and you're not
talking no no we're living which I know
I have a podcast which is what I do is
like God talk a bunch but I actually
actually don't love to talk to all
people all the time no really really
so let's some moment some like Jo was in
your house who would walk I'm like hey
what's up yeah hey well hey chuckle what
do you think about this and just be like
just like turn and walk away like I
think I'd be like looking at me Mike
wheeler to me 400 you don't want to talk
to you so what don't get all butthurt
over it he's got like stuff on his mind
like I'm hungry
yeah so that's kind of cool I'm looking
forward to going out in that on in in
September and I'll report back with how
it goes absolutely man there's a no
pressure shooting a freaking bow and
arrow at I am
it's no joke novio will be will be 30 or
40 yards away
yeah nice outside of that like III can
loosely hit a target you know wow you've
been priced like yeah practice I
practice but you don't wanna you don't
want to have a bad shot nobody how are
you everything good like shooting your
bow like 50 yards
I'll hit all the time good to go okay
yeah like I see your bad example like
how can I stand next to you it's like a
fucking tambourine and make you like
shake because nothing you'll be like
laughs then any like that man Nick when
there can screaming it's it's the
coolest thing in the fucking world I
swear to god that's awesome well I don't
know if you want to get her you want to
get a bow and start hunting I'm here one
thing at a time I don't even know I'm
doing after this podcast probably going
across the street to Buffalo Wild Wings
get all gooned up so bruiser I mean you
know like I said there's a million
things to talk about to you bruiser but
when you got done with T you bruiser
what were your what would your like
looking back on it not looking back on
it now because now you just look back
and everyone
but when you were like when we got back
two weeks later what were you what we
look back at it from that closer
perspective I I was kind of lost like
he's not gonna get any better than that
you know like I was in the next troop
I was the OP Steve then I got fired I
didn't get fired I get fired because I
made senior chief and I was like well
cool all right
and then I had to go to the senior
analyst Academy and it was like whatever
and you know and I went the team seven
and I pretty much got fired which was
fine I didn't want to do that anyway and
those in ranges and they're like we
needed a guy to go do the Provincial
Reconstruction Team I'm like okay so I'm
like in Afghanistan in Afghanistan so I
went to Afghanistan why did this work
out for like two months at Camp Bay in
Indiana so this is a this is a mission
will you be going with not with like a
seal platoon but you're going with some
other kind of ad hoc group of people
well no no no I was it was I had a seal
lieutenant commander as the CEO okay
when I was a seal senior chief and we
really only SEALs and I had about a
hundred people from the Navy the army
the National Guard
so it was an Air Force so it was ad hoc
oh yeah and on it it was it was like
leadership challenge I'm not used to
working like with the regular but I am
used to work with the rhythm eteri
because every frogman has to so really
wasn't that bad but I had like very very
minimal combat experience I had a couple
of guys like these old crusty guys who
are in the South Carolina National Guard
some guys were in the Rangers they were
awesome man bunch of they're all like
cops lot
or do they must alive oh yeah or or
prison guards you know and National
Guard cats they were friggin awesome you
know once we got through the language
barrier because I'm from New England you
know they're all from South Carolina
they they were badass man they were like
a platoon that was mine my platoon you
know and they were friggin great they to
a to a guy every one of them was awesome
I had some reserves Seabees who took
care of the trucks you know my guys with
no convex but never even driving these
trucks you know mortars coming in they
performed magnificently it was it was
cool but I did a lot of vehicle work
with him you know immediate action
drills how to deal with down people you
know we got some we actually got some
pretty good training you know I learned
a few things I'm not afraid to admit
when I learned something from you know
but we're they're like here you know I
broke off for like month month and a
half and just went back to my seal
buddies and got half there it got a
bunch of gun fights and you know we get
mortared all the time I'd beaten a
sandwich and rock Chinese 107's come in
like you know whatever but you know it
was cool what was what were you guys
actually doing we go into areas and like
we wouldn't build schools we wouldn't
build bridges we would facilitate it
going there me with the village elders
and I say we need this okay
so we'd sent up a proposal then we'd go
back give them money mm-hmm you know or
put it out to bid and of course that's
all garbage it's just a big like
shakedown all the local politicians just
to just come in and take the money and
they're like okay we'll give you okay
let's do give him $50,000 to build a
bridge all right so the guy wins the bid
his company gets the 50 grand the
politician comes in and takes like 30
and then they built the bridge so the
name $10,000 now they come back and go
we don't have enough to finish we give
them the rest of money I mean it's like
20 percent of the 40 percent 30 I don't
know what it is
percentages all shakedown money that
were given new Afghanistan was like
crazy mm-hmm but you know people think
in this country that every other
countries like us yeah no yeah well I
remember that and I don't know if
remember we've got to Ramadi the one of
the things that the guys were concerned
about was they were like hey des the
officers and the Iraqi army are taking
the enlist their skimming out is up and
then it was like you talk to the Iraqi
there's a well he's the boss of course
he's gonna take us some of my money yeah
scam that's the way it goes you know and
we were all thinking like like in
America if you heard that
hey the officer is skimming money for
off the enlisted guys's paychecks they'd
be like oh that guy needs to be
crucified
right over there you're like yeah they
were like men well yeah of course he's
taken a little that's his he's the boss
it's not like it's like people over
there go like this they see it on the
like 6 o'clock news with you know
whatever shit you know she's up there
going oh today the scandal was don't
know there's none of that it's just
whatever it's all Wild West just do
whatever you got big guns you get all
the money the vid you spent that that
year how many like different villages
did you guys go try and God like all
kinds of them yeah how would you get in
there were you guys doing patrols in
their vehicle patrols you flying in
we rarely used air assets we have always
had air support them at least standby
but most of the time we drove vehicles I
had somewhere between a dozen and up to
like 20 vehicles mm-hmm and I was
usually the vehicle commander
I wasn't overall in June after the
operation yeah sometimes I was mmm but I
took these people who never really been
in a military vehicle that much and we
were okay survived few ambushes got
bought up a few times and had wreckers
with us
refueling tankers I mean it was crazy
these are some long transits that oh
yeah
a hundred miles some of them one way the
ie D threat was was it was gigantic it
was gigantic like I said we got blow up
a couple times but you could tell was
amateur hour so back then like said back
then we had three big threats one was
your trip wires or we were manual mm-hmm
you know and then you had pressure
plates I should play it zoom activated
yeah so you pressure plates so the way
we count we countered pressure plates is
you got the mine rollers and they're
like an 8,000 pound thing they put in
front of either a mat V or a whatever
the other one is I had in my own bat V
it was awesome but so you've roll that
in front and of course I had a driver
mm-hmm
you know but you can't just drive with
that you have to counterbalance the it's
weird and you have to learn how to drive
it so that's like driving a trailer
reverse right
you'd have to put eight that 8,000
pounds of pressure whatever it was maybe
I'm wrong and it would detonate if it
does detonate it's not it's gonna fuck
you up but it's not gonna flip because
you know how explosion works goes like
this so we had that for the pressure
plates for the so you had some
countermeasures for the IEDs yeah and
you ended up hitting just a couple yeah
just come you know but around us guys
hit a lot yeah we had to respond and we
got pretty good at like going out not
really being a a QRF but going out and
providing support and and I would fan
out and I'd walk up and talk to who's in
charge yeah what can we do you know but
Afghanistan was kind of cool because I
really loved the terrain mm-hmm big
mountains like couple thousand eight
that 9,000 feet up
it was pretty cool it was actually
beautiful there yeah could have ski
frigging lodges and you know it's that's
Northeast Afghanistan out west like
desert but it was cool and then I came
back from that and I put my papers and
retire and it was just like went back to
9/11 running the boys but I basically
had a great crew they pipe hitting guys
they just knew what to do so I I kind of
like get up in the morning and have my
coffee they hit the gym for a bit maybe
go for a run and then jump in my side by
side with my 12-gauge and go shoot
rattlesnakes and eat lunch and then do
that some more go out to the range look
around everything good yep come back to
the camp like watch hockey and drink
beer all night I'm pretty good I was
like I gotta get out I gotta retire
though on that and that's pretty much it
you know just terrible get out let's
just you know I mean I did some contract
work for a while yeah that dried up and
then went back to and you know
landscaping & construction type work and
that sucks but it was cool what are you
gonna do now you're retired now is that
right oh yeah I mean no I mean like
retire like yeah you're not going to
work everyday right now no no I guess
that's what I mean by retirement not not
this summer not yet so I'm just kind of
like btf and around yeah it's actually
kind of cool
hey I got some questions yes and this is
a great first question it's very serious
in retrospect what's the dumbest reason
you've ever gotten into a bar fight
probably be easier to figure out the
smartest reason you ever got into a bar
fight
Wow I'd have to say Far East Rock one
night like watching Monday Night
Football and the Patriots were losing or
something and someone said oh you know
what it's cool because you know I don't
have him in my fantasy flick darling and
I just went fucking whack and I fucking
smack the guy I don't know like it's
just terrible
like I just I was pissed and drunk and I
don't know that was pretty dumb yeah
sounds like a good one in 20 plus years
and the team's
what situation challenged your
leadership the most and how did you work
through it I probably have to say when
when when Mark Lee got killed I have to
honestly there of course and I mean
that's kind of a weird question and I'll
get to that but I I had to like shove
that fucking shit deep down and not like
show it and make sure that I was there
for the rest of the guys cuz the milks
on the floor obviously you got to find
out why it happened so we don't do it
again what the fuck you know sometimes
there is no answer but I had to push
that shit way down and focus on the
tasks at hand whatever they were the day
I couldn't just go hey Jocko and like
I'm a bag of shit I'll see you in two
days I can't do that I know so I mean I
and I push it down before but that I had
to really really really push it down so
that was those challenging I mean other
times like leadership that guys that get
DUIs
we intercepted the mail hide it from the
cops so they never got DUI just take
care of it on your own out in town and I
can say that because both the guys did
for dead hmm so I mean I had no problem
like fucking cutting through red tape
but yeah that was probably the worst
what was your favorite qualification
school that you attended while in the
teams oh that's uh that's easy it's a
cross through in Sniper school and the
tracking course yeah I was fucking great
yeah yeah really good there must have
been a human that when you were hunting
yeah man you must have just been like oh
yeah he'll be overjoyed
oh my god yeah but like track an elk if
you've never done it it's you don't have
to go yet oh you you look over
especially if there's a little snow
mm-hmm there's like eight billion tracks
is there in a herd so it's not like you
look at me I can see it for like six
hundred yards away like yeah but there's
no snow there because it was just you
when you listen to these podcasts when I
had this guy till John Stryker Meyer and
his buddy Doug the Frenchman Letourneau
on they'd be out in Laos or Cambodia and
there was trackers there was NVA
trackers with don't yes that would be
common after they carried as part of
their standard loadout they carry pepper
like dust and and some other rules the
damn
coughing met it was the coughing would
tear gas tear gas powder they had that
so they they put that on their trail and
they'd hear the dogs like hunted the
dogs becoming so then they trained him
and then also need to start freaking out
and then they'd bring up another dog
skip that area and I said I said to tilt
I was like do you do you I said you must
hate dogs he was I hate him oh yeah
a we we would we trained on how to
defeat him and it's like one way there's
there's several methods but I mean I'm
not gonna say it on here like how to
defeat him but it's so simple and it's
got like nothing to do with the doc
mm-hmm it's like crazy mmm
it's it it works - I did exercises you
know and like I mean
so I'm asking the cat and like hey mate
you know these dogs like they're they're
good at like exercises like oh now might
they're real dogs they're gonna bite you
like fuck just gonna suck I better
fucking be good at it enough you know
going over my notes okay what the you
know oh yeah they were like police dogs
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna get you we
thank God I mean I did it right but I
holy shit that's one thing it was a real
world off right yeah you know I gotta
m16 blanks yeah you know cuz it's really
nothing in New Zealand that can hurt you
mmm wait there's no poisonous snakes
there's no New Zealand's freaking
awesome
man it's friggin wonderful the people
are awesome yeah that places yeah oh
like Maury's you know they're like so
cool
that's one of the places I would take
you in like this like okay yeah that's
one place I went to I was like this is
just awesome like I could live there Oh
in a minute in a minute I could live
here
that place is freakin amazing yeah it is
if you could go back in time and give
yourself one piece of advice before
joining the teams what would that be
hmm I don't know I don't think nothing I
wouldn't do it any differently I liked I
could say I would have did this but I'm
glad I did stuff like as a knucklehead
and had some hard knocks and no I know
no I wouldn't done anything differently
mm-hmm cuz the good the bad stuff that I
went through made me better and a good
side you know that kind of shit but yeah
that's one of those questions too it's
you know this is there's people that ask
there's a nice there's people that ask
these kind of questions they're looking
for they're looking for like a one like
a one thing I answer of like you know if
you could tell yourself here's another
cool if you if you go back and tell
yourself your 20 year old self what
would you tell yourself like it's or oh
yeah yeah invest in you know what is it
Apple Apple or whatever oh yeah uh
what's the one leadership lesson you
like there's always that kind of thing
or they ask it about everything man like
that people ask it about everything
what's the one book you would watch in a
they ask the same kind of question that
there's never an answer yeah I mean it's
like when I figured out early on is like
okay you know what book cool about face
somebody asked me yeah at somebody
somebody asked me that in the live
podcast and and like I talked about I've
been talking about about face since I
started talking to cat cora's public
yeah is awesome and so this guy at the
live podcasts in New York sunglasses if
you could recommend one book and I'm
like does anyone only yesterday every
was a cop-out face the game he asked you
that question or you could easily say
like my more like cracked magazine it
was about the same yeah yeah so it's
weird I'm not trying it you know it's
like people want to hear they want the
information to be so distilled down but
it's kind of like this kind of got to do
the work yeah
kind of like being in jiu-jitsu and
being like what's the one move you
should know in jiu-jitsu it's like mmm
you know there actually is not one move
so asking Tony what the one piece of
advice it's like man like where what is
that where do you stick to your guns
probably is good yeah don't don't give
up when you know don't like get away
from your weight and I want to say
principles I hate that word but you know
whatever you believe in like the team's
like for me I was like now you know we
know we you know you don't do this you
don't do that like if I'm running a crew
and everybody wants to make more time
off and then you kind of give in no now
here's what I'm doing that's it if you
stick to that and there's you can't blow
up you know disarm a bomb that already
went off mm-hm
so just stick to what you're doing
unless it's so fucked uh of course but
you know I had this my my second platoon
commander the real squared away guy but
we we did a hydro at Camp Pendleton and
like we went to read be there was a
freaking nightmare it was freezing and
waves were huge
we go out we do it frogmen is it and
then we get everything recovered we come
back we sit there in the zodiac typing
up the freakin message with the little
codes in it for how the beaches we come
back we get in we draw them you know the
cartographer guys don't take all that
information and draw the maps and blah
blah blah blah and we and then the
Marines launch we even we land the
Marines yeah yeah and then the Marines
weren't happy with what they did they
weren't happy with the landing so I
think I'll reload so the next night
they're like okay you guys going to go
dude we're doing the whole thing again
ruin everything again yeah so hydro
recon so we go out and all of us boys
were like you know we just did the hydro
you know nothing's changed there's
nothing changed and that boss that oh I
see he goes that's not the point
he goes he goes I
clear as day because I'll never forget
him saying this because I use this coin
about a million times with all my guys
he goes you're right he goes hey guys
you know we don't have to do the hydro
again but would that be the right thing
to do
yeah you got it and I was like get your
lead lines boys I mean that's how right
your bank your biggest right is the guy
in the mirror yeah that's the one you
got an answer to not anyone else guy in
the mirror yeah that that like I never
forgot that from then on from the rest
of my life it's been like what's the
actual right thing to do right now yeah
what's the actual right thing it's
usually the one that's so fucked up in
the hottest way yeah yeah it's gonna
suck yeah it's like everything yeah
well I could do this or I could do that
no which one's hotter yeah well then
that's the one and a problem should do
you and then nine times out of 10 you're
gonna be right yeah yeah
does this suck this way is easy but this
way sucks okay but that's the one I have
to do yeah cuz then you if not you're
just like I should've did this but I'm
just all weak and stupid and then you
just get all mad and you end up doing
that anyway so mother just do it and get
it over with as a sniper team leader
prepping for deployment in European one
of the top five things I should drilling
my guys wants to support combat
operations limited range time about one
range every other month I wouldn't be so
concerned about range time I'd be
concerned about environmental shooting
like nighttime low light sundown sunup
communication between each other not so
much like snipers spotter or like
areolas just put yourself in a in a
360-degree you know white side black
side whatever and communicate okay you
got guys all around how are we doing
this we got too much shit over here do
we need to shift forces yeah
need a range to do that you don't need a
range you don't even need to carry
weapons to do that you know you
obviously have to shoot yeah but and
then cross training all the other guys
on the sniper weapon because sometimes
you have to take a break and you got to
give somebody else who's not a sniper
doesn't mean you can't shoot a gun I
mean it's easy but do more cross
training on there's no reason that a non
sniper and a seal platoon shouldn't have
a thousand rounds through whatever
weapons system we're using right now
there's no reason maybe a thousands a
little bit but at least couple hundred
there's no reason with that but we're
that busy you know getting up and going
to work and like running around and
talking about uniform standards but we
can't I mean come on we got all this
time you have like no one shooting at
you back here so you should like
maximize that time you know don't get me
wrong you need time off to drink beer
and be frogmen but job is a job what did
you do to keep Jocko in check getting
nothing that's very terrible that
question I know that's an important
question to like someone who doesn't
know you I don't know maybe not like
destroy everyone in the morning jujitsu
sessions so like when they had to
actually do something I had to yell in
there other year because that
cauliflower ear fucking torqued yeah
basically hey man this guy not in our
chain of command who's like working in
another department he's limited you
don't know him but I do he's not you
kind of got to be not a frogman but kind
of gotta be a little gentle with this
guy because he's good at what he does
just don't go in there and
Karam death cos he's just gonna like
fade into the shredder room and cry so
you know maybe that but very limited
yeah you can do with this fucking gag no
I think people and we talked about this
last time wasn't like I mean first of
all you and I were like if you and I
looked at a target we would come up with
a salute the same thing because why
because if this paper is the target like
when I look at it I look at it there's
nothing in my head but that you look at
it so here we go oh yeah yeah yeah okay
no you look at it like really really
look at it and envision what what this
high ground here what's on top of that
high grass or trees is that how can i
okay I need to take this section of the
map and I need to add the other five
because we're coming from here so I'll
add boom boom boom boom and this and
then egress this way if this is my any
point so next thing you know the maps
the size of this fucking room that's how
you look at a target you know just look
at go
oh yeah well I'd go in here what who
says you got to go in there's a hundred
and fifty ways to do this mission but
you have to look at that target mm-hm
and really really look at it and then
envision it in 3d as you're walking up
to me that's I think that's what we do
pretty good yeah I I just always
remember like I'd you know some mission
whether it was overseas or well no
matter what now I'd be like looking at
it going I think it'd probably be good
to do it like this and then you'd be
like why why don't we do this and I like
Yelp yeah I mean yeah there may be like
one little difference but that's that's
my new I think with btf Tony can you
share some stories about team guys that
influenced you in good and bad ways
during the early days and the teams oh
yeah I mean
we've been talking about that the whole
time I think one of the reasons I picked
that question was because it said eating
good and bad ways bad ways I just think
not being totally totally 100% team guy
I've seen some guys who in charging me
that you know they just seemed at the
time a little more interested in you
know just getting through what we were
doing and not vewy you know it's like a
chief two weeks ago when we're doing
this can I I want to bounce my notes off
your as he's like I don't have any notes
Mike hmm all right that's terrible mhm
that's terrible why don't you have any
notes like isn't this like the pinnacle
of your fucking career because for me it
was mm-hmm and you know yeah I get it if
there was no war going on but still
isn't that like that's why I say some of
these guys were champions like most
respect fucking awesome cat some of them
they kind of put us behind the power
curve when the shit really hit the fan
after 9/11 because they were just kind
of going through the motions and they
didn't like before we got into the
mobility world that they'd never they're
like oh yeah will either get dropped off
by Hilo and hump in or come in by boat
wait what about vehicles well we don't
really do that we mean we don't do that
are you gonna get from point A to fuckin
be you know and once we started doing it
it was a bunch of ketchup mm-hmm it took
fucking smart guys like TK there to
really ramrod the mobility program and
and do that kind of shit and like when
you guys think of this I mean yeah I'm
why didn't I think of it yeah I kind of
did but I was a lonely or low guy trying
to learn the ropes you know and I don't
think this is any favors I didn't think
about it I didn't think about mobility I
didn't either myself like oh cool what
up but other guys that are better frog
man or q1 cats we're doing it the
what I what I like I was still trying to
sort out what just yeah might be a good
team guy right but yeah looking at it
seems like those days there was there
was seem like you would need we needed
as a community to look at like what
could happen one one writing thing that
I was looking at when I was a young team
guy was I realized a long fuckin time
ago that there are no terrorists
really I mean I'm wrong about some
things in Afghanistan but there are no
real bad guys in the middle of fucking
nowhere there's gonna be buildings
there's girl it's gonna be it's not
gonna be a person with combat and then
out in the middle and warfare in
Illinois it's gonna be a nice yeah and
as soon as we got rid of the sub guns
and started carrying long guns for
close-quarter bow that's that's one of
the styles yeah and it was all it was
always gonna be a mix whether you're
coming over the beach yeah you're coming
in even going on to a ship yeah oh yeah
because people were some people want to
stick with sub guns cuz you're going on
a shit and I love the sup guns oh yeah
you're sure if they're awesome for sure
but at a hundred-yard fan tells ya god
yeah or a hundred and fifty yeah you got
you could have some issues yeah big
issues yeah
at what point in your career did you
start to feel competent in operating
killing the enemy and making sure your
brothers came home with you did you
start to feel like you could do it every
day and be successful yeah I always felt
that way yeah well how many platoons did
it take before you started feeling
competent I like one I mean I always
felt like I was good to go yeah I could
do this I can fan I have fantasized but
I'll admit it I couldn't wait to kill
anybody I loved it because that's your
job like and it was it was kind of a
letdown like was I you know you think
like in the movies you know you train so
much so I bang alright on the next one
but yeah I felt it right away it
not that that was never the issue the
issue has always been confident as a
leader mm-hmm
that took a while it wasn't an immediate
it took it took me a while how good were
you as a as an LPO when you're 85 I
thought I was pretty good but when you
look back on it no I was okay because we
didn't have a lot of I I was basically
really good at the basics yeah I see I
always felt like well once I got done
with a job I would want to go back and
do it again and I'd feel like I would do
it so awesome and you don't get to do
that right you don't mean you know I did
a platoon commander I was like oh but I
you know I did fine yeah but like as
soon as I got done I was like I should
have done this I should have done that
as a tu commander I got done I was like
yeah sure done this I should have done
that just want to do better well
absolutely I mean LPO thing when you're
a peacetime LP oh no I was always mixing
it up and everybody seemed to like me I
mean they didn't bitch too much couple
guys did but it was all good you can't
do everything
yeah all the team guys under your
friggin belt there's gonna be guys go he
was a fucking asshole and he just
fucking did this was stupid of course
it's gonna be that you know but I think
for the most part I mean I did all right
try to I mean I could have done better
like telling people how oh you know you
you're doing good and you know it's okay
no I'm glad I was a dick kind of tough
but when I say that not a dick but a but
you know that you say that like and Lafe
pointed me this out to me the other day
and he remembered it it's funny because
I had just written about it what I wrote
about was like if a platoon it at land
warfare was doing good I wouldn't say
like this is when I wasn't ready
I wouldn't say hey you guys kicked ass
as a task unit I wouldn't say hey you
guys I'd say hey Bill you and your fire
team did a good job holding down the
black side of that target and hey Mike
when you grab that other guy and you
flank those down on the hill that was
awesome cuz but I would never just say
collectively uh uh awesome because then
what happens is they all fall apart yeah
yeah and that's what kind of what you
did to you used to if somebody if
somebody did something good you would
tell them they did good
yeah if but you wouldn't be like hey
everyone did great
no because the chances of that's like
false like oh you know everything you
did was amazing this is amazing
everything's amazing that's so fucking
stupid I hate that like you did your job
like what do you want a fucking medal
now here's your mat oh there's an MRE
and go over there and be stupid go gear
shit ready we got another Ross and
besides you know it's not like I talked
down everybody these are my brothers
like yeah man that was cool that's about
the best team guys compliment yet yeah
hey that one alright yeah good job yeah
okay cool that's but yeah on to the next
thing
yeah guys like yeah I gotta go to the
head whatever it's like no big deal last
question do you still smile when you're
here stand by to get some yeah yeah
that's pretty cool I mean come on it's a
you know it's gonna happen
and you know on after a while it's a
fuck yeah
yeah bring it you know it's like that
cat there when uh Ted Williams Ted
William Teddy ballgame mm-hmm I mean he
was hitting 402 and he had the two games
series and they're like man you're
hitting over 400 just don't play you
know you're the only guy who's ever hit
over 400 he's like fuck that and he went
like three four five
and he went to like 406 407 and he
risked it all because yeah I'm playing
the money this is a guy who took time
off fly jets in Korea or Vietnam or two
and Korea
I mean like yeah what are we gonna do
like okay we got it we're going home in
a week well we're not gonna do this up
fuck you we're not gonna do this up you
know then you know we go home I mean
what if you died right before you so
what that's why I'm here I mean if that
happens it happens because a fuck I mean
it's what it is right
that is what teams and shit that that
trumps everything
it's like teams of shit okay I'm a team
guy that's it all right done yes and be
good to see you good to see you brother
good player out good to see you man oh
he's freaking awesome to have you back
on yeah I'm glad I could man and
hopefully I'll see you up in Maine if
you can swing by yeah that'd be cool
I'm sure a bunch of people are gonna
want to meet you up there I told one of
my cats back home he's like oh I'll
fucking Drive the Harley down there all
sad echo yes speaking of standing by to
get some what do you got how can we be
more prepared to get some as they say
many ways all right well one way as we
always say is jiu-jitsu Tony feels a
little bit about that as well
um when you do did you to me peas right
unless you do a noogie but we recommend
ghee and no ghee so when you get a ghee
where do we get them or Georgian so this
is so Tony's from New England and you
know Tony and I were talking yesterday
and man if you grew up in New England
then you saw the economy get just
annihilated yeah and whether it was the
the factories that were shutting down
the textile factories that were shutting
down the clothing manufacturers the shoe
manufacturers all these the paper man
Falcone yeah got shut down and you know
it's one of those things that when I
when I talk to companies and they say
well you know you were dealing with you
were dealing with life and death and
we're not and I said yeah but you're
dealing with people's livelihoods
and what would as a as a as a mom as a
dad your livelihood is how that's your
life that is your life and so if you
grew up in New England and a nun newing
that's not the only place because it's
all over America when you're
manufacturing got taken away and sent
overseas it's a nightmare
you go up to these towns and there's no
work not that people don't want to work
believe me they're New Englanders they
want to work yeah and I keep saying New
Englanders because but it's everywhere
but it's a forget it yeah Americans want
to work and so you know with origin and
when you come up and see the factory you
know we got 45 or 50 folks now employed
in Farmington which is awesome Maine the
up Farmington Maine and you know it's
like are they employees yeah yeah
they're employees because they're
working there but you know what they are
they're part of what we're doing yeah
they're not as something part of
something yeah they're the ones that are
actually making the the gear making the
jujitsu Keys making the jeans we started
making geez I'll get you some jeans when
we get up there yeah boots we're making
boots I'll get you some boots when we
get up to Hartford like we got folks
that have been out of work for 14 years
it's fucking stoked and you know getting
after to be back they want nothing more
than to come in and and get on those
machines make the boots make the jeans
we just started printing to you like
we're doing everything and we're doing
everything so I'll bring you up there if
you guys come anytime I can't make it up
then you can come up whenever you want
yeah I'm gonna open pass to go to the
factory in Maine and check it out and
see you know it's it's just a beautiful
thing to go up there and see a town
that's and this is just a starting point
man yeah and people people can think I'm
you know dreaming I'm not like we're
gonna build this thing it is gonna be
massive we're gonna bring back
manufacturing to America and there's no
one's gonna stop us that's not gonna
happen
no one so if you need something like
that if you need AG if you need a rash
guard you get it
from origin main comm if you need a pair
of jeans go on there and get them
somebody said these jeans are expensive
and I said you know what I said you're
right you're right they are too
expensive right now they're they're not
at the price point we want to get them
down to but as we build more and grow
more we'll be able to get those expenses
down but we have to start somewhere
yeah I can't obviously give them away no
you gotta pay the people yeah we got we
got to pay the workers so we're getting
there we will build this and there's
nothing's gonna stop us yeah I don't
think they're that expensive anyway
well well they're cheaper they're
they're more expensive than a pair of
mass-produced jeans from China in a
sweatshop with a plane with they're
paying their employees right literally
50 cents a day so yes our jeans more
expensive than I find lasts forever
they're a hundred bucks don't ever you
buy two pairs it's a hundred bucks
so anyways that's the deal and if you
think that's if you think 100 bucks is
too much hey man I get it
save up save up get yourself a pair of
now really yourself a pair of jeans made
in China that are made in a sweatshop
where you know some the corporate the
core the corporation is gonna make all
the money and none of its gonna come
back here to America so all right sorry
I'm getting a little crazy
don't buy jeans there's other stuff too
which is also tons other stuff so what
supplements so important supplements to
keep you in the game joint warfare krill
oil which I had an experience and didn't
even know it when I went to Hawaii you
went off this I went off didn't even
realize that you know the krill oil and
joint warfare to you and here's the
weird thing my elbow is it is you're
correct yeah it was amateur band I
didn't even realize it till I got oh so
I go you know and I was lifting oh yeah
oboe I had it so bad this one yeah but
yeah if you go on the joint warfare and
krill oil okay if you don't have someone
give you some it's good it takes like I
guess depends on who you are to me like
six days for to like
really start that's only a couple days
more than a cortisone shot though really
yeah yeah right yeah that's like two and
a half days you will do it like you go
and read the reviews of joint warfare
and there's people that are saying oh I
couldn't do I couldn't I couldn't lift
my whatever you know I couldn't swing my
ham or whatever I'm back in the game
melody oh yeah yeah so completely sludge
yet so I come back and I'm like okay let
me get you know back into I was like man
I wasn't lifting that hard in Hawaii and
not as often either so I'm like why's my
oh my god oh my gosh totally hit me I
was like dang yet another instance of me
playing myself but proof
you see I'm saying anyway so yeah stay
on that joint or fur and krill oil
there is also discipline mmm good deal
dibs on the discipline train big-time
I'm with him on that train everyday
pretty much daily yeah hey Lee disappear
yeah in all things and this is this yet
another one yes
also milk if you want additional protein
in the form of a dessert by the way the
best desserts oh you know I never would
have thought what I'll do is make a
dessert yeah that's that's got protein I
wouldn't think that because it doesn't
seem like it's a possible feasible thing
yeah but then it turns out to be yes it
is one of that's yeah I know John go a
long time one of his favorite sayings is
not actually as saying he's just like
talking to you cuz you're next to him
going stopping starving right now
always starving like every like okay we
know we ate like an hour a half ago
fucking so hungry
really yeah well not all these crazy
fast like intermittent fasting yeah well
it gets a milk yeah tastes good
get some tea some jakka white tea and
that'll ain't don't forget about the
warrior kid milk yeah which i think is
the game changer yeah he's gonna be guys
from back home a lot of guys watch
podcast but can you just go over the
Oh calm again whatever it is Oh origin
or Georgian main dot-com main as in the
state right ma i ne-yo yeah yeah or do
you mean that comes we get all this
stuff also Jaco has a store it's called
Jaco store of course he's super creative
with the names and a lot of thought in
yeah man it's good turned out good um
anyway that's where you can get that's
shirts who was it it was I think Flynn
Cochran he was he was saying that the
original Jocko product was because I
used to give like a brief the leadership
brief to the to the guys that were
started and he's like they they called
that the Jocko brief and I didn't think
about I was like oh yeah that's like the
original the original chuckle Prato
product yeah and then so I can't be just
blamed on lack of creativity from my
part well yeah you can I guess I can
yeah actually yeah and also you got
asked the question did fling come up
with that after no chuckle but yeah no
it was it was I mean Mike's relly same
thing like oh this yeah did jock will be
you know what though when you kind of
think about it what do you call it like
phonetically or whatever I don't know if
that's the correct word but like when
you say Jocko it's kind of matches you
know like jock ghost or Jocko brief it's
not like it's like you know you know
yeah the whole line is because you know
that story that you just told about me
being hungry the reason this whole thing
started with Jocko
is because when I was on Tim Ferriss is
pot ass I fasted that day and he was
like well you know we've been talking
for a long time maybe we should go get
something to eat and I went Jaakko
hungry like I was just joking you know
but then but not really it didn't like a
little while later it was oh we're gonna
have a podcast and I was like okay Jocko
podcast almost like I'm a knucklehead
podcast that was the original buzzy
sound Oh
unless it's like if you're gonna name
something like that starts with an O
that's when it wouldn't really work like
if you like o ocean Jocko ocean that
kind of sounds good I guess
no I take over an ocean somewhere well
stores where you can get shirts
discipline equals freedom boom
more rash guards on there too by the way
dope which are which are origin rash
guards yes sir they named America mm-hmm
choco taco that works that was good
choco taco oh yeah Paco's tacos I need
to start a taco shop well why not yeah
might as well
jeez often around here in San Diego
Farfan yeah oh yeah maybe you can't find
one taco shop around here where my
daughter who's my oldest daughter comes
home
then she'll like fly home and she will
stop at a taco shop oh yeah and stay
away from the airport
that's just asada oh cool it's looking
forward to seeing you you need to be
home in ten minutes he's like no no I'll
be home in a half an hour because I'm
gonna get a taco well absolutely
gonna get a California burrito oh I
hadn't liked three of the last four days
so good just can't change that so cool
ocean chuckles tacos and chocolate or of
course like we're saying um shirts rash
guards hoodies hats you know all kind of
stuff you're gonna represent while
you're on the path boom good place to do
so also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already if you're into it mmm if
you're into subscribing
super easy oh yeah on Google Play
stitcher iTunes you know don't forget
about the warrior kid podcast for the
children stories not just questions but
stories from uncle Jake about how uncle
Jake got his values in life what made
him say I should be prepared you know
what know how I tell a story uncle Jake
goes on a little on a little there's
there's a little rowboat and Uncle Jake
and his buddy when he's eight
to go out on the rowboat and while
they're out a little bit he says I you
know we're not we don't need life
jackets cuz you know we're just cuz nice
day I paddled around here so they're out
in the rowboat and they're clowning
around or whatever and let go the oars
for a second they both slip out through
the through the oar locks and there's a
wind blowing so within five seconds
they're they're gone from the under the
middle lake yeah and they have to drift
all the way to the other side and then
borrow some but you know there was that
moment where things were bad yeah so
that's when Uncle Jake learned you need
to always be prepared for things to go
down that's an actual story too by the
way those that really have that and that
really happened to me so there you go
stories of Uncle Jake on the warrior kid
podcast so get some of that also
speaking of warrior kids it's a word kid
that I know heard of myth it's not a
myth not real real name is Aiden making
warrior kids so not worry kids help
Jocko so he's the warrior kid that's now
we got two ducklings are getting out and
that sounds good to joke with soap
there's also trooper soap by the way
which is like another woody call flavor
if you will
soaps not flavors right don't eat it
like we know that use it to wash up and
it'll help you stay clean yes very good
smells like Irish it smells like hey
that would be awesome to make mouths
like war it smelled like cordite or
whatever oh yeah powder good yeah yeah
it smells like napalm
yep victory in the morning well jock
awake tea tastes like victory
don't point well yeah you know when you
say it it should smell like wore that
kind sort of made me think of how you
and Lafe and actually all you guys would
tell us how war smells like some powder
in the sewage yes terrible yeah that's
actually the terrible idea yeah yeah
okay like the range the range smells
good you know good diesel fumes in the
back of a sea Fox now or when you're in
a helo and refueling like in here and
in-flight refueling don't think I've
ever done that it's absent powers of
just diesel everyone's just like just
like and I don't like ever get sick but
that stuff but I was like I've gotten
yeah I got seasick three times once was
in the back the sea Fox fell asleep with
the diesel fumes just in and the next
one was an LCU I was downstairs in a
raging storm water proofing the radios
in the engine room it just diesel
rocking all over the place I came up and
started yakking in the and the BMC that
was run in the LCU was hanging his head
over the side yakky sounds like all
right I'm cleared hot technically is
that getting seasick Velvets from NASA
whew I don't know yeah I never did it so
yeah you got C sassy there never happen
to me nonetheless the the the scent
aroma of the troopers open the Jocko
soap is pretty good not okay and very
functional by the way you're still
talking yes it's very important I mean
we could talk about the diesel fuel
fumes seasickness somewhere if you don't
want true I'll take the hit nicely no no
I'm taking up to this job up to you
you're doing doing a good job anyway
take the hit also we have a youtube
channel beat you have Tony into YouTube
or one
not really but yeah yeah well I would be
surprised if you were but you can get
addicted to various videos nonetheless
we have a YouTube channel with good
videos video version of this podcast
excerpts enhanced excerpts enhanced
means that echo puts all these effects
in them like well I got a watch that I
have these explosions these are on fire
absolutely yeah but yeah YouTube channel
jockle podcast boom also psychological
warfare psychological warfare yeah
what is that breath it's enough you
always get mad at me explaining it don't
have the best Xcode here's here's a
psychologic word if you ask for an alarm
clock which is kind of where this
started if you're if you're asking for
an alarm clock that has me telling you
to get up there's where you get it
psychological warfare it's on iTunes
it's on Google Play it's on a mp3 he
actually started when Eko asked me a
question about something and I was like
here's the answer and then he was like
coming to record that mm-hmm and then we
just went from there yeah that's cool
the question was what was original
question impressive one and it was with
me was with workouts so like when I
workout or when I plan a workout and I
just really don't feel like it and you
know that's a common thing like well you
just do it anywhere you don't be a beat
ef3 all right so I'm thinking man I wish
I was better at btf in through it seem
sane I wish I was too lately it's a real
thing so I'm like I won you know cuz I
can imagine you know jock will just be
tester or some like but what do you like
say you know like what what goes on in
your mind do you just not think about it
at all and you just sort of
automatically do it do you say something
or I don't know like what what is it you
know what a message I think two weeks
ago I turned 51 and a mic actually made
it past fifty gonna fucking be nice it's
got to do some right yeah you know
especially when you think you're gonna
not make it to 30 you know for sure oh
yeah I'm like mm there you go it doesn't
get any the old everyday you get older
it gets terrible you wake up you're like
oh what is this now here what's this I
realize you know how I've said one of
the things I noticed about getting older
is and I don't notice that much and I
don't admit that I was it either so even
if I was in a ton of pain I wouldn't
tell anyone but one of the things that I
have admitted is that my first couple
rounds of jujitsu
I'm I'm I was a couple rounds of warm-up
now you know especially especially if
I'm going with Dean and Andy
so Andy didn't used to be
this bracket he's in there now so
where's the other thing that I noticed I
I once mine because I couldn't run when
I hurt my knee and so now that my knees
like getting better I can run again not
you know crazy but what I noticed is
same thing if the first like the first
half mile that I run I just I must look
like a person that just never run before
and then the longer I run what I mean
the first half but you run more when I'm
coming home and I'm once I'm warmed up
I'm like oh yeah cool cool and that's
one thing that sucks is when you were
young you just didn't have to do
anything and you jump dude no you didn't
do anything for three months and then
you show up at a team they're like hey
we're doing a nine mile run today you
better Cole just got do it and you're
fine
now you'd like mmm the first come first
half mile you got a flat tire let walk
run the show terrible yeah if you want a
visual version of little things to keep
you on the path then go to flipside
campus comm Dakota Meyer he's got a
company there again made in America made
right in Austin Texas making cool
artwork I'm trying to think of a better
word for that cuz I don't like saying
you don't match I know same artwork
I know bow is it a better word I don't
know no no I think it's artwork visual
inspirational shit no inspirational
might be worse yeah I mean it's worth
saying it I dig it it's inspirational
stuff actually not really know what for
a lot cool looks like canvas calm yeah
for whatever you want to call it you
hang it on your walls you hey yeah you
know why he named it that cuz the last
thing he said to one of his one of his
teammates in Afghanistan was alright man
well I'll see you on the flip side yeah
and everyone on his team died
that guy hit and so he's like that's
what this is that's a good name and
horrific for men so support Dakota and
his company flipside campus.com he's
making all kinds of good cool graphics
does that matter I fix it on there but
that's not the end product
hmm I'm gonna think of something
eventually maybe I'll make up a word for
it like Molk yeah maybe yeah do that
look about it
watch this choco canvas yeah that
doesn't matter no from the last also on
it so on it calm slash chakra this is
where you can get worked out gear
there's some cool DSM do you do sand
bass did you watch my uh little clip I
put out my edit yeah I did I didn't pay
max attention so you got sandbags on
that yeah okay yeah yeah by the way if
anyone of that that band that I clipped
out there it's called life's blood it's
an old-school hardcore band from upstate
New York that's from an old 7-inch that
Elgin James sent me because we there was
a great band there great band they're
the the lead singer is now a cop
somewhere in Atlanta or something but
anyways that's life's blood I don't know
where you can find it but that's the
music on that use video that I edited in
email by the way I'm gonna take echoes
job from them that's frigging dangerous
maybe I'll take a rational in front
maybe do the briefings on that yeah
let's see that maybe I will check so
anyway what I was trying to say about
the sandbags is when I was getting stuff
yeah from on it I saw the sandbags those
like I'm gonna get this I don't have a
sandbag routine yet for those wondering
when I was doing the sandbag I pick it
up throw it over my shoulder turn around
pick up through my world my shoulder
well over again how big is it
I don't how heavy just I don't know my
son when he came home from wrestling
camp and he was like you know kind of
kind of walking around he did two weeks
wrestling the really good wrestling camp
called J Rob 14 day intensive wrestling
camp awesome camp and they they put
these guys through the ringer
it's wake up in the morning conditioning
breakfast wrestling lunch wrestling
dinner conditioning and they do that for
14 days straight to graduate you have to
the last thing you do is a 12-mile run
so like it's and you're all beat down
when you're doing that so yeah when he
came home from that you know he was kind
of bowing up a little bit
oh yeah they've been yeah he was bowing
up and I said oh you handed them the
sandbag don't get do this this this and
this seem like that sandbag yeah all
right well I'm gonna take another look
at that because I think I'm gonna get
this in there you should definitely get
one also yes kettlebells on there that's
where all my kettlebells are from and
yeah a lot of good stuff on that go
there on it calm slash chuckle hey I
wrote a bunch of books weigh the warrior
kid war your kid to Mark's mission
warrior kid 3 where there's a will Mikey
and the Dragons and this one it goes
Freedom Field Manual extreme ownership
in the dichotomy leadership these are a
bunch of books I wrote if you like what
we're talking about here if you're an
adult get the adult books if you're a
kid get the kids book if you have kids
give them the kids books and you might
want to check out the kids books even if
you're an adult yes so there you go
Ashlin front that's our leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership go to
echelon front comm for details so what
we do all day every day EF online this
is leadership training online
interactive and put you on the spot ask
you questions when you when you become a
leader or when you're gonna become a
leader you're not gonna learn everything
in one shot and just like an armlock you
don't learn it one time and now you're
good you have to practice and that's
what EF online.com will allow you to do
we got the mustard next muster coming up
September 19th and 20th in Denver and
then December 4th and 5th in Sydney
Australia extreme ownership comm for
details if you want to come to sign up
right now because otherwise it's gonna
sell out they've all sold out
and of course we got EF overwatch
when we're taking proven SpecOps leaders
and combat aviation leaders and placing
them into companies in the civilian
sector that need one thing more than
anything else to win and that is they
need leaders and if you don't feel like
we've talked for a long enough and you
want to talk to us more you can find us
on the interwebs tony is at frogman NH
164 do you think you know your password
yeah I got it somewhere yeah people are
gonna want to like ask you questions
then you can be like yeah 99% of its
gonna be that's 99% of my text package
for Tony's yeah it's ridiculous you guys
should see it if I if you link up with
me and we're talking anyway Jocko what
were you guys talking about a bit yeah
yeah check this because I don't really
erase anything with that his Jacko's
text like 70 lines my T's crying dude
what are you on a crapper so I have all
this time I can do like three lines and
he's like and also echo and I are on
Twitter
we're also on Instagram and we're also
on the fusion of Bugan she bruising
broken echo is that echo Charles and I
am at dock well I can't go anything else
no Sarah nothing else tanks ETF Tony
thrown a girl's brother pleasure and my
brother now man thank you for having me
on
good to see you guys and a nice pad here
now is it's good to go never been here
yeah awesome
like to shout out to all my friends back
home you know if I don't anybody and
everybody I know and I'm in San Diego
right now and all my team guy buddies
and my girlfriend Becky and my you know
my off back home and all my chums back
there now see you guys soon thanks for
having me on
always a pleasure guys your class act
we're an and teams and shit of course
thanks for coming back on again
obviously and hopefully I'll see 150
episodes yeah right firing 50 episodes
since you can you are on episode 41
we're now on to 191 Wow
it's crazy it's ridiculous yeah we got
to do next time we do this we gotta have
someone in here like with me someone
else with me because this is like one
and you know I I'm running I'm not that
interesting I can't remember any shit
half the time
know what you should do is next time
we'll listen to this one and then go and
write down notes of what you want to
talk about next time I'm like like five
stories or whatever
oh yeah things like whatever if we could
get on like someone we were talking
about at my first LP ode somewhere like
yeah I get someone like that on yeah
with me
oh yeah sure just me yeah with you guys
yeah yeah no man anybody any of them
doesn't want to come on I if I could
have him come on
that'd be you sick I'll ask them yeah
ask him and yeah man we'll do it again
and seeing me yeah we'll see in Maine
thanks for coming back thanks for man
thanks for everything you did thank you
brother
you know holding that thread that I was
talking about earlier that thread
through the years when there was no war
going on there's plenty of people that
you know they did their job and they
went on their deployments or whatever
you were freaking toeing the line man
you were toeing the line and and keeping
that knowledge base improving that
knowledge base that's what you did to it
so that when we got to war we were ready
so thanks for doing that
my pleasure for the teams thanks for
everything you did for bruiser of course
and as far as I'm concerned you're
actually the model of the American
fighting man oh you're the motherfucker
that went up against the Japanese and
the Nazis and said you know what we
don't care what kind of warrior culture
that you
have we got something else we're
Americans and we're about to fuck you up
at Shh
I've got something that none of you
other countries have I'm gonna go what
like fucking John Wayne if you can
produce anyone a quarter as good as that
man
then I'll maybe listen you we have
fucking John Wayne best guy ever in the
history of ever you know my you know if
you monitor yourself to him in everyday
life then you got nothin to worry about
what would John Wayne do he there go yes
no or punch you good and then he'd have
a bunch of whiskey and then you know
shoot a bunch of people and get on his
horse and go have a steak and smoke like
it's one two hundred cigarettes good
plan yeah good plan
yeah awesome everyone else all the other
veterans out there that have served
thanks for what you've done those that
are serving right now thanks for what
you continue to do to our police and law
enforcement and firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers BP Border Patrol
correctional officers Secret Service all
the first responders out there thank you
for your service here at home and to
everyone else out there you know you're
gonna make mistakes you're not going to
be perfect things are gonna go wrong and
when things go wrong it's pretty easy
just to say you know what I'm gonna
stand down I'm gonna take a knee or I'm
gonna give up and you can do that or you
can do what Tony would do which is grab
your gear and just grab a knife and
you're at EF until you get things back
on track and that's what I recommend you
do
so until next time this is btf tony and
echo and Jocko out